une production du studio sf météo sans
filtre le podcast on parce qu'on veut
que nos invités d'assister à chanter
avec moi de plantes
cette semaine le sans filtre est
présenté par les cidres lacroix l'essai
de la coiffe un groupe
les cidres lacroix pardon en fait c'est
une compagnie familiale 100 % québécoise
c'est des produits qui sont fait à 100%
de pommes québécoise pas de gluten c'est
pas trop sucré c'est parfait pour l'été
c'est dispo dans toutes les épiceries
bhl dans toutes les dettes du québec
c'est aussi en fut dans plusieurs
restaurants
moi j'ai fait une collaboration sur mon
compte instagram avec les cidres la
croix ils ont reçu pour un déjeuner
genre de brunch dans leur vie dans leur
verger la bosse était vraiment
magnifique c'était bucolique pour
utiliser ce mot qu'on utilise trop
rarement
c'est vraiment une gagnante vraiment du
fun avec la gang lycée de la croix puis
je vous le conseille en fait chez qui
c'est chic ma soeur en tout cas ne
prendre que son exemple adoré les sites
une grande consommatrice de cidre si
vous trompez pas folle birere si vous
voulez de quad un petit peu plus léger
d'un petit peu plus fruité c'est parfait
pour vous fait que fixer sur l'enfant
vous allez le voir en boire pendant le
podcast et ses messagers messager ville
rose ouais c'est le tessin en podcast
c'est juste bien tous
big ben ouais bah merci à fait juste
bien merci à ganges décide lacroix
pourrait encourager le podcast arrête
cette semaine ont reçu 100 breton un
humoriste tellement drôle très drôle à
chaque instant de chaque moment le
tripoli sur scène c'est exactement le
même gars qu'on a devant connu devant
nous dans le podcast tellement drôle qui
tellement
inspire le comme la majorité des invités
qu'on a ici un gars qui qui qui c'est
qui ce qu'ils s'envoient qui c'est qui
qui qui ça peut faire plaisir à personne
mais qui fait de lui mots puis qui est
drôle entre leurs mains pour vrai on est
tellement ri les podcasts il ne coûtait
pas de casque on conneries aux larmes
celui ci se fait partie de la gamme
c'était super le fun onu du groupe les
airs puis ces dix des dix-neuf ans a
aussi fait que c'est vous ouais c'est
clair
quelques petites annonces en elle sans
filtre vip qui est disponible sur notre
page piquionne il ya beaucoup de monde
qui sont abonnés aux pitchouns
dernièrement chemin avec le sans fil
viiip fait que les fans de voir que ce
qu'on fait vous intéresse on va
continuer à en produire le plus souvent
possible ensuite abonnez-vous à notre
chaîne youtube à notre chaîne balado
commentez participez à la discussion de
ligne ou de vos commentaires vous allez
voir dans le pot test avec ses
amendements dont fait un appel de
commentaires le fait que les nouveaux
commentaires sur cet c'est pas de
castillon les bras quand on les lit on
aime soit on aime ça et que vous
participiez en fait à la discussion
puis je pense que d'autres sites sur
instagram moi ma quête pour devenir
fluorescent continueront de 2300 c'est
claude roy être tranquille je vous
faudrait que je me mettais j'ai beau
maillot en plus que ça vaille ont jamais
travail ou arrêtent fait qu'est bonne
écoute
ouais bon podcast
[Musique]
s'allumant à l'aube ou deux
merci d'être leur 22e fois tu étais je
pense que le premier tout pays dans le
studio
oui bah ouais ouais ouais mais pas de
cast avec des t bonds parce que ça
existait dit prêt à écouter ya là à
penser que mars est la devise de vie
aussi je crois
[Rires]
et ouais bon segment suscitent nos
segments où nous parler de tes maîtres
les conditions propices à faire un bon
spectacle
c'est moi et s'étend de la musique sa
mort doit interpeller c'est parce que
tellement souvent on est dans des
situations de ma vie je me suis jamais
vu le lancement de laurence nerbonne
vrai pas longtemps c'était comme au
district saint joseph à québec typicité
comme de jolis reid ouvre avec la rbi a
été comme un ver qui s'obstine j'ai dit
le mot famille rideaux ont voté on va
installer une vague puis elle le fait
depuis comme le shoot est cent fois
meilleur mais si elle est peu pris le
contrôle de la place s'arrêter donner un
truc c'est exactement ce que tu dis là
dedans c est en tout cas de facem et
faut 6 h qu'est ce tu veux inquiet oui
parce que sinon c'est pour ça que je
disais c'est les gens qui veulent une
zone qu'on fait ça dans ma vie mais
c'est à nous de prendre les devants
justement mais il y en a trop qui
justement c'est peut-être pas dans leur
personnalité
s'il ya quelqu'un avec un autre mais on
va le choix paraît alala détriment eux
la seule chose dont journée après comme
tout fermer 7 et comme vous le faites
très bien installé dans le top
l'éclaireur on ferme les rideaux la télé
tout est prête si ça vaut la peine ce
nom le lieu change absolument à tous le
cerveau des foyers déjà qu'il voit en
spectacle comme un ch'ti stade raoul
tabac j'ai vraiment passé de belles
soirées
les autres partent avec ça six mois plus
tard à une party de noël augert
vainqueur à bolton en tabarnak la meinau
partenaires aussi fausse bonne idée de
344 345
c'est encore liste à part la personne
qui m'a engagé puis je pense trop tard
puis ont trop bu c'est bien voulu fermer
ces succès n'ont laissé top est très
importante c'est ici si ce site il met
aussi ses défauts une trop petite gagne
des fois ça lève - parce que tu es plus
de monde non plus soit ça rit ou soit sa
danse et de musique
il ya un effet d'entraînement au 6 août
il est tellement pac-3 bien des pions
placé avant aussi le site le post
les gens aiment pas nécessairement il
s'attendait pas soit ils sauvent in fine
et d'amants âgés ayant bu qu'un qui
n'ont pas des conversations notables
comme josé anigo connus il ya un nom des
corps paul martin à quel point ces pôles
humoristes en soi mais le set up c'est
souvent les partys de bureau c'est
l'heure une fois ou deux par année qui
vont avoir ce d'ailleurs j'aimerais
l'accompagner c'est rare qu'ils sont
tout le monde ensemble
les collisions à 9 10 heures je vois
deux volets une heure de ta soirée
pendant leur mentor les autres souvent
ses seuls leurs sous texte - l'énergie
qu'ils dégagent et roizy mais chez nous
c'est ma compagnie si moi je peux pas
des causes et s'initier à la bastide
cambrai fénelon et l'a fourré sur le
téléphone le masters si je reconnais
pour moi une heure à corpeau souvent
mineures mais souvent ils vont demander
une heure
même si je fais une heure d'abord sa
voix de tête cachée - petit comme c'est
un stade à la fois celle abandonnée même
suis pas encore aujourd'hui je suis au
stade où je peux faire moi ça c'est une
honte c'est ça je demande si c'est pas
ça je m'en contre sus le cul je vois pas
plus grave le sait mais mais souvent ça
va être une heure pour tout vous dire à
cuba s'ils veulent une heure je vois les
députés le montant souvent ils vont dire
oui effectifs et une m'ont fait c'est
moins chiant faire une heure caducée
malheureusement c'est triste que je veux
dire mais le monde le chèque pour lequel
jean jacques au repos c'est souvent moi
je le fais tu le fais un peu pour
l'argent mais des fois à l'inversé des
corbeaux merveilleux et bien pays ciblés
est-ce que c'est essentiel à la carrière
d'un humoriste est ce que tu pourrais
pas vivre sans corpo eux je pourrais
vivre sans repos c'est juste que c'est
[Rires]
l'afrique
non mais c'est ça c'est plus financier
pour d'avril ouais qu on le fait parce
que sinon c'est c'est plus souvent
qu'autrement c'est pas le x men ou
encore paulo à tabac mais ça m'a
vraiment lancé le vélo lâche tout est
légal s'ils n'ont c'est beau c'est beau
je les estime entre la tête
[Rires]
ouais c'est souvent finale les 4
commence été payées 100 fois moins cher
qu'un évidemment après cinq ans mais
pour toi ce moment là c'est beaucoup
d'argent si comme décor pour de marge en
effet 1 puis un autre sachant très bien
que je m'en lisait dans un bon rendement
bien chauffé est fait mais j'ai rarement
cette cache très mai mais maintenant je
sais relate à toutes les compagnies ont
fait une mauvaise une chance que ça je
peux le dire parce que l on ne savent
pas à qui je pense a présenté parce
qu'elle n'a pas été parfait ce sens
c'est pas ça c'est rare mais souvent ils
me le demande je leur dis mais c'est mon
erreur qui vont se demander mais des
fois quand je vois que la personne veut
bien faire petit que ça peut être un bon
qu'au repos des fois je vous le dis il
me dit à savoir perdre estimé andré je
ressens une bonne personne
d'ici je dise pas su recevoir d'autres
humoristes oui on aimerait ça commençait
une tradition à chaque noyau mais si
c'est le code un pauvre çà çà çà çà çà
c'est non c'est non c'est non c'est non
puisque rappelons le talent est souvent
ils jouent et qui prennent des petites
notes puis parce que je dis si on est
beaucoup d'humoristes un petit milieu
jeudi soir le tout comme au juste dans
mon agence battant on revient du corps
paul c'est moi je t'avais que sheryfa
neuf là on est quand même une c'est moi
c'est sur un jour d'épiphanie comment ça
a été je sais être lama pour de vrai
c'était catastrophique personnes et
coûté un autre niveau
black list plomberie varennes la bande
fixe et souvent ils en prennent bonne
note
comme on va faire attention car
l'humoriste souvent toute façon et
disent toujours que le mot risque et à
l'élève l'année d'avant le tonton ph7 du
bourg je t'appellerai plomberie
baragouine ont les moyens mais sarlat
qui en fait des modifs je vois tu je
vote pour mais souvent ils veulent c'est
juste que c'est parce l'on sait que le
plus souvent les les erreurs qui font
les erreurs qu'ils font il valoir est
trop tard votre rapport c'est trop tard
il va faire tout les tirages pis les
parents de cadeaux avant toi mais c'est
souvent ce qui les rend si c'était à 450
pièces rester dans la télé tout est
donné
cette période le tirage tout le temps
trop long qui tout le temps oui bordel
placé comme à qui l'uci et oscar l'ip
lait polop les cours après moi ce qui
est payant aussi dans d co repos comme
ça c'est d'avoir un master cérémonie
capable alors gaston il va le faire y
est drôle au bureau mais ces deux mondes
les gaston il va façon rendu le show
s'est finalement éteint rennes lille fra
toilettes en chantant du rhum des femmes
mal au vert c'est que ça marche ça c'est
tout le talent pour ça que tu es d'après
le supprimer maintenant il va te faire
passer entre le plat principal dessert
c'est non c'est non c'est non
avec le traiteur le service les bureaux
musique hard disk jockey et russes là
cia depuis deux ans il va un peu trop du
film fait leur accorder sa folle
faiblesse comme elle aussi ses sorts en
mousse de monsieur elle demande un arrêt
de service moi j'en ai vu des mariages
pendant mille ans que je connais la
vague des traiteurs fait comme si tout
allait demander un arrêt de service on
peut pas faire ça je dis pas les vols
saudi autre état je peux aller voir le
traiteur ça me dérange pas mais je suis
mal traitée avec un mois
ok c'est souvent un autre sans faute et
lave la vaisselle du début du tout pris
pendant ce temps l'aude en cuisine tout
est arrangé il faut juste que du bon
vouloir de chaque côté faut que tu le
saches moche et quand je filme et ont
des conférences le pic
enfin j'ai l'impression la personne qui
organisait aussi qu'on ait tellement bon
genre ouais comme personne qui écoute et
voit en tout le temps et je parlais de
trucs qui a valeur de 5 ans est
complètement c'est tellement une espèce
de foot courte dans une voie au centre
d'action qu'avec du monde qui passe à
l'arrière qui regarde je sais pas c'est
pas cool mais la personne c'était
vraiment parce que c'est parce que c'est
du monde connu qui parle des fois c'est
vraiment vrai que pour un autre atteint
la cible mais des fois c'est parce que
tu racontes ça peut passer une fois que
la fille a vient voir les malades admis
numéro un c'était parfait coûte rien à
dire et puis j'ai l'impression qu'à
sentais que c'était de la merde
puis j avais dit j'ai dit pauvre on se
connaît pas beaucoup mais je pense qu'on
est deux êtres humains capables de se
parler
je pense et je dis je je crache pas
atteinte à peu forgé partie de la manne
pourrait rester aucunement plaisait j'ai
pas eu de femme tombe on n'écoutait pas
tant mais si quand même de m'avoir
engagé
c'est juste en disant ah ouais là comme
baisser les armes
ouais c'est ça que je le voyais rh et
c'est la chose que je peux faire c'est
sûr que je te voyais rush et un poulet
c'était scarpe lala com avoué ouais
j'avoue c'est comme on dirait que c'est
pk tu essaies de me faire croire que
c'était bien moi je fais ça quasiment
tous les soirs je sais ta premier sinon
ouais t'as pas parfait du tout du tout
le set fait chier de partir de la pizza
qu'il ya du monde qui pense qu'ils se
disent qu'ils sont bretons il est
possible rôle que ce finalement t'es pas
posé la question d'un début rapidement
j'ai mis sur le côté et basta vie éco
[Rires]
premièrement
les cours que je me dis si tu fais ton
jugement bien cimenter à mon égard par
rapport à un corpo n'est pas capable de
voir faire que les conditions de la
merde
ben je veux pas nécessairement devoir
dans ma salle et je pense qu'ils
comprendront même pas le deuxième degré
de mon humour fait que fac non le sais
pas ce que tu veux puis vite à vivre
vivre la mienne pis pas grave
puis à limite marc vérin jouait pas
assez souvent à ça les gens et hydroliés
badauds n'ont d'ailleurs c'est quelque
chose qui me fait capoter
on est en 2010 9 entendre des gens dire
allez j'ose il par lâcher vite moi même
été tués ces deux derniers shows surtout
son dernier
non ben c'est sûr bellefeuille qui
crient toujours mais belle feinte as tu
vu oui qu'on l'a connue rapidement 10
mai le distinguo brillant bellefeuille
il fait rien à moitié son show et et
c'est ceux qui crient mais c'est
beaucoup plus nuancée alors moi je peux
y avait des cris compris ce que je viens
de tête les gens sont trop souvent que
c'est comme j'ai vu une fois c'est fini
c'est comme ci comme ça mais en même
temps tu aimes tant que maison tu te
mets dans la peau du public dit il ya
tellement de choix en humour qui a
tellement le choix qui s qui mettons que
tu vas passer un spectacle qui te papa
un bon moment du troc le climat restée
pas les prochains thèmes pas son style
du monde est ce que vraiment se donner
une deuxième chance considérant toutes
les autres options tout est totalement
non je comprends surtout comme syndic
peut faire un minimum un soir par
semaine pendant un an
tu pourrais toujours l'espoir nantes à
raison de deux bouts de relève relève
expérimentée saison on est vraiment
beaucoup mais ça je le comprends mais
c'est juste des fois je trouve que 103
cette voie cette sentir qu'ils auraient
une opportunité un moment donné d'aller
le voir une deuxième fois
une pique il répond c'est ça des fois
que vous alors riel - mais c'est qu'elle
sait qu'un rôle c'est dans son premier
galop mais oui mais quand on lit ça son
premier galop inexpérimenté puis avait
dit avait juste sept minutes à dix
avaient le gars dans le fond aussi parce
que c'est sur une heure et demie par
sept minutes c'est des fois moustiques h
20 gars là là
dans le fond c'est vraiment chaud une
immense et je ralentis à des silences
c'est juste des fois puis là je parle
animaux mais en musique ou six a mis en
musique
j'en ai entendu et puis je leur dis pas
que je connais le band des fois j'en ai
entendu mon père m'emmena on les avait
vus mettez vous avez vu ou genre les
festivals de la courge à mascouche avait
vu en première partie qui fête ses cinq
ans peut-être sur vu comme leur propre
show a eu le temps non je te dirai quand
je l'avais vu j'avais trouvé ça assez
mauvais ouais mais j'arrête cela jusqu'à
maintenant mais c'est changer les
pignons de québec est quelqu'un une fois
que c'est une fois que s'est forgée
changer ce team and en tête du monde
martin matte et fendant macau divulger
pythie chacune des personnes de tout le
temps plus nuancée lille complexe que
même des gens que j'ai tué ma mère
évidemment c'est la femme que j'aime le
plus c'est à toi maman aussi pas de
jugement mais aussi des fois faut que je
fasse attention à la salle de gym si ma
mère au site et demi d'euros
mais là encore des souvenirs de leur
première apparition le début au début je
rame et idées ont fait différents shows
la tipp ici c'est vraiment folle et
maintenant c'est sa richesse a embauché
l'os pour s'acheter dit le lion -
challenge est il nécessairement mais
c'est des fois j'ai j'approuve arrêté
jeu clairement comment pierre il ya une
autre à williams a déjà fait en corpo
dans la liste de lille l'a vraiment la
vraie de vraiment catastrophique
puis le la semaine d'après cet hôpital
de québec d'une madame tu avoir eu chaud
un certain capital d'une situation
parfaite
le son ou la salle le monde tout est
elle là madame vient boire a dit moi je
t'ai vu l'une semaine dans l'est de
l'île
c'est ce qu'on verra pas mauriac québec
pse son mari qui l'avait amené à ce que
vous êtes bien le net
j'avais pris mes soeurs j'avais vraiment
pas trouvé de rougemont du gepci golo ça
pourrait m'arriver c'est voici je te
voir asseoir un des meilleurs moments
niveau que j'ai passé à jeanne va faire
réfléchir puis maintenant je dois faire
attention dans quel contexte je vois ces
mêmes c'était même la règle numéro ma
famille mais même à fin mai ou au corps
pour
nan mais c'est sensiblement les mêmes
choses mais dans la dernière demi heure
je me suis mis avec les six qui essayez
d'écouter jeu manqua au lycée
essentiellement je pense que ce soir là
peut-être temps que j'avais fait la quel
point c'est la perception du temps note
qu'en théorie la réception vraiment
lamballe à leur contenu des conteneurs
qui est tellement l'effet d'entraînement
numo aussi comme si des fois c'est kim
tout le monde rit autour bcw ivoiriens
aussi bien les personnes riz il y aura
en train de s'implanter alors si tu veux
pas être lui aussi le seul à rire ou le
seul à courir dans une situation de
marmoutier vraiment envie de gagner
il ya des salles aussi des salles les
quelques sages comme à sagesse a joué
l'homme la plupart des humoristes on
s'entend là-dessus
c'est immensément de la façon que ses
consuls plafond et all balcon il est
loin c'est plus fête de la musique c'est
la musique le son il va il ya comme tout
comme ici dans le studio il ya plein de
choses comme pour amortir le sont ouais
mais allez rire là ça veut dire que le
voyage dont le rire comme se soulèvent
mais sera en poche s'arrête dans sa tête
des camions crise un sari dessus où ça
arrive pas le type s'est sévèrement
facto bien même des saxons micky pieman
dans les salles mike le public
cb - mais comme car l'egypte advantage
je reste dans ta bulle parce que si tu
connais cette [ __ ] et tout le cycle
aujourd'hui ont du plaisir
mais ces facteurs de dix ans maintenant
que les autres bah oui c'est ça surtout
que c'est cette phase de rodage c'est
rohff le 4e un texte moins 150 fois que
tu fais tu je sais que c'est drôle 4
c'est pas des places devra pour leur
grade et là mais aucun feedback fixé sur
le portrait de droit ou de suspendre à
oublier t'es pas de ben ouais c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment bizarre alors
que tu fais la même affaire dans une
autre salle son voyage les murs sont en
beauté ou sont en ciment puis la cds
comme la bordel comedy club et il le
sait vraiment on s'entend sur ce point
de salles s'est installé pour avoir pour
l'autre fois c'est vraiment parce que je
pensais que c'était pas mal on s'est dit
c'est petit mais même si c'était plus
gros un peu limité quand même à obérer
sa leçon là le real à sa perte de tous
bords de côté tout fait envahir tous
dessus tu vis le moment le public et
encore plus le mot reste aussi une
notice est carrément comme un sac de
montres plus tueur unis
je t'en donne que j'improvise plus que
c'est la balle à 4 4 grâce justement
d'enfoncer ce site à blagues marche pas
une fois faux populaire là bas la bande
à petit le parce qu'ils ont peut-être
juste une question de circonstances
après combien de fois mettons le recul
est bien court mime silence on pense
qu'en général basse comme un classique
de trop qui arrivent tard près la
troisième fois sa part in ses fans en
deuil
ouais ça fait chier dgac
puis trois humoristes dans le format des
foyers comme les trois amis un peu chaud
il ya des choses les enfants qui vont se
rejoindre
on a fait ça comme le mode humoristique
s'enrichissent et plus ça en ferait la
loge mais public qui s'épuise le
comprendre public que tu ferais pareil
comme un autre la musique et non à
l'oubli comme dirait luc senay que j'ai
connu à l'école de l'humour y est dit
non là la petite crotte sur scène - et
il faut te fasse l'amour au public à
tous bonne note
kroos seul jour sans fin d'année sans
pourtant ça va marquer par langage mai
puis des fois c'est cette charge et le
pacing des fois j'ai des numéros texte
pour textes sont plus forts plus haut
dans le show qu'il avait numéro par
rapport à mon père puisse un euro qui
n'ont quand même pas mal de jus faut que
je sois assez hype itx et 17 minutes car
même cour mais c'est un numéro qu'il
faut que je transporte sur mes épaules
puis a pas vraiment de pause p puis à
faire une chose mais si tu as peut-être
république est fatiguée un petit peu le
tir si je m'arrête plus je me mets dans
leurs souliers sont francs et un petit
peu ça fait une heure et quart et 20 moi
aussi je veux pas fait une heure et
quand les 20 que je me donne le goût
maintenant je le montre dans première
demi heure 25 minutes du show et 30 mai
avant de l'enlever une audi fait six
hausses
c'est bien
tout à des numéros aussi des fois le
faux faux tu place des clés le temps il
faut qu'on commence aussi tout ça avant
c'est bien plus drôle après parce que si
tu nous dis que tu aimes les chiens mais
on est tellement proche de nos affaires
que c'est bon d'avoir des tailles
d'extérieur et convaincant mais c'est
assez évident que ça change tout
enfin calvin dans le vin gagne souvent
d'ailleurs de la barousse de trop mais
sinon la collecte à 1 millions de
possibilités
c'est fou c'est fou depuis qu'on que
contient plus avec des guest on pique il
ya des conversations avec des buses
maurice pendant qu'on est derrière la
console j'ai réalisé à quel point
l'humour c'est vraiment plus complexes
gel pensé avant ouais c'est moi je
pensais que c'était comme des grilles
des numéros des cris des gags mais s'il
ya tellement de travail qui va derrière
un nombreux convois ne pas juste un an
beurre mais maintenant un one man show
qu'on voit là quand on écoute un spécial
et flex ou areva
il ya tellement un chemin que tu amènes
le c'est fou moi je prends moi je parie
que tu écrivais le texte mot pour mot
s'il restait mais c'est pas du tout
enfin chacun sa méthode non mécanique
est vraiment à chaque virgule était
placé épique et ja mais tout ce qui est
écrit beaucoup sur cinq
oui ça se pourrait qu'il y ait beaucoup
de monsieur leubou de cul qui sort qui
sont pas dans ton texte
surtout quand tu fais de rattacher on
appelle ça des petite béquille tout à
côte sur des petites expressions faut
négliger ou d'insectes moi je vois ça
crée plus en rodage en chaussons sont
plus placés parce qu'un bon tabarnak qui
est le fun oui si t'as pas dû tabarnak 3
x 20 mai mais chacun sa technique le
témoin
je suis en direct les racontant je me
compare pas eu loin de dole et michel
barouan même jean-marc parent seulement
le blanc aussi c'est beaucoup de tout
cela mais je me suis comme ça c'est sur
cinq sur cinq soit sain pour ça moi
qu'avec mon âge enseignements donnés je
leur avais dit je veux faire un show
caché dedans le sam club c'est mon site
web sa boîte au point quand je lui ai
annoncé juste au cercle avec steve comme
privés oui puis j'ai fait le show gratis
cacher j'ai fait comme a pu le jour des
faits des fois mais fait que je peux
utiliser le show caché mais c'est comme
ça c'est un petit sa leçon à personne
puis s était 1h30 d'idées de caussens
d'affaires que j'ai jamais et comme
développer je le développe les devants
aux autres mandats niveau je me
surprenais à improviser 15 minutes mais
oui des fois et des sujets à près d'une
minute par le coup n'a vraiment pas les
aéroports n'ont pourtant jamais à chaud
gratuit dressions de ça on en a découlé
un bon mais oui c'est pour moi c'était
beaucoup le style c'est comme cma trou
numéro ça ce qui est faux de dire que
caisse à 1h15 de stocks que j'aime mais
c'est pas grave c'est ce qui m'a permis
de bâtir ce fut chez nous oui en
écrivant dans des cafés moi ça me tue
moi je m'assois pour écrire le s'est
fini c'est la mort dans l'âme bigey je
suis pas t d eau non plus casser le
poignet - café 4 mai mais ça c'est ma
façon de faire cela dit un accès
complètement l'inversé n'y a pas de
bonne ou mauvaise méthode et moi c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne puis par
rapport à précision dès qu'est ce qu'on
disait tantôt juste pour fermer la
parenthèse des fois il ya des gangs que
des gars que tu fais longtemps dit que
tu fais plusieurs fois demandé les
séries pue ça c'est grâce à ses récents
débuts dont seulement série efforts des
fois j'avais une clope plus des fois de
voir et écouter ton audio
des fois ça la vitesse que tu le dis tu
prends cette confortable dans ton numéro
non mais m
blablabla d'ananas espagne nanananère en
tout cas il ya des fois où je recommence
à dire plus vite un style rires oui
c'est ça me fait capote je me rappelle
j'avais écouté nous et vous n'en avait
plus dans quel contexte qui expliquait
que le fait qu'ils jouaient la batterie
saleh de boucau animaux parce qu'ils y
apprenait des rites de jobs le lui il
faisait là
la blague baladera papale ap ap le fc
fait la coque sur le cul d'une [ __ ] tu
sais comment c'est drôle car toute la
musicalité
ouais c'est important de la trouver
quand on dit trouver sa couleur je
trouve que par la bande ça veut dire
trouver sa musique ou si c'est moi j'ai
un rip que j'ai encore quatre lots
vaccaro pop et c'est ce qui fait la
force avant même de mettre des mots
c'est que ces commentaires c'est comme
mode à mayol de campagnols mais des
choses que je peux dire que j'ai pour un
panneau expliquant la face dans ma façon
de le dire vraiment fait que c'est ce
qu'ils font mais la vitesse le rire
autant que celle errer dans un gang que
décélérer ça fait toute une différence
c'est sur cela après le texte en fait
avant le texte la personnalité de la
personne que tu as devant toi puis sa
couleur ses six thèmes importants on
attire des yannick de martino des gones
même qui qui sont frayés ou con côté
spécial c'est comme si après ça vous que
le texte le bourbaki médecine ça prend
une espèce de quelque chose de mouillé
dans des spéciales du niqab enfin
surtout qu'on eu beaucoup de visites
entre oph un moment donné je vais bien
beau aimé l'humour
je peux pas tout la consommer non c'est
quand une palette de couleur or aux
normes c'est ça se peut que j'accroche
jusqu'où la ccl tortue des mers essayer
ça mais oui ça par la personnalité il y
en a vraiment qui sont opposés je
connais déjà dans la vie sur scène un
feu d'artifice en lice on s qu'est ce
que c'est un peu propres chante mais
mettons disons compteur ou raconteurs
est-ce que c'est propre à ces gens là
parce que c'est le tout ne racontent des
anecdotes depuis tantôt ce ça pourrait
un petit peu travaillé à être humble et
y mettons l'histoire de la fée qui
quittent eux quittent écrivain qui est
venu de voir à québec après d'un show
ici ça pourrait être tourné en numéro
aussi parce que c'est une histoire qui
est racontée avec tombes dont on
attitude avec la façon avec laquelle tu
as raconté ça pourrait devenir ce est-ce
que c'est propre racontant d'être
capable de juste est quand même dans vie
aussi être capable de raconter les trucs
de façon le wii ware vraiment c'est un
bon point quand même parce que moi j'ai
eu m j reçus dans un décor un corot à
l'université à lire cela va on avait
reçu fred pellerin puis ces frais
pérenne sur elton c'est chaud puis comme
tu penses que ce qu'ils racontent s'est
écrite ici comme tellement poétique
tellement un conte de fées que tu dises
sera peut-être de l'avoir et critique
oui c'est écrit sauf que il est dans le
court plon il pose une question sa
première job étudiant pelé se met à
raconter l'histoire sa première job
tabarnak on dirait que c'est un show de
fred pellerin j'ai ce parce que la façon
avec laquelle il raconte les trucs et
dans une classe d'université les paons
train de faire un show ait jamais écrit
sur sa vie ce texte lui mais moi je
pense que c'est comme si dix points
chauds sur quatre universités mais quand
un public moins le tacatac tablettes
dépendront non sens plus relax et puis
encore là des fois quand je cours temps
de raconter de quoi qui s'est passé ces
jeux
des fois volontairement je vais
recommencer je vais en beurrer plus
épais juste l'affairé sa fin jeudi à
bail 2 8l tête à la france ce n'est pas
vrai l'homme est essentielle mais juste
à être l'oeil c'est juste des justes
vous trois maintenant un microphone
micro tu me demande de me raconter là
comme la fin de semaine j'ai pensé c'est
ce qui est activement il y avait quelque
chose d'une petite fille qui s'allument
intérieurement de hockey mais ces
sommets vendredi s'essoufflant
improvisée de la guinée à travers le tir
parce que ça aurait être plus fort que
moi faire c'est ce que le branchement
ces rencontres on ne sait même quand
jacques simon leblanc
une banque est un très bon ami de
quarante genre ça c'est bon c'est pas
possible at il dit
il remporte la médaille d'or
un bon ratio à l'aller par gilles
m'appelle pour me parler mais big roger
sénié microbatt amène sa post suppose
généralement un groupe c'est quoi mais
je pense que la plupart c'est un autre
affaire il pense un autre histoire
c'est venu je sais c'est merveilleux
mais je pense que ça vient chercher la
firme de rencontre on peut pas
s'empêcher nécessairement de damas
policiers leur accordant beauty crise
mais tellement compté pour vrai plus
vendre de la viande autour de l'os les
témoins ont un début et une fin bière au
milieu ouvert betis et c'est tout ça et
c'est mais je pense que c'est pour ça
aussi que fred pellerin à l'université
lui a vu l'opportunité mais elles sont
30 dans une classe crissement votre
raconté baisse va plus souvent
qu'autrement comme quand j'ai fait deux
espèces de chauves cash et moi même ne
savait pas aussi je m'en allais avec la
pression les regards du public
c'est souvent là que ça montre sa part
je me surprends moi-même à dire des gars
que je n'aurais pas pensé que j'oublie
aussitôt c'est pour ça que je
m'enregistre parce que moi je me
recouche comme asti c'est vrai j'avais
tout à ça c'est bon je vais regarder le
sport c'est pour ça j'ai jamais cru sur
scène c'est l'apparition est un allié
mais moi c'est ça qui m'amène à une
drôle c'est bon c'est ce même façon
lorsque j'avais jamais réfléchir ses
coûts j'ai aucun doute qu'à michel
barrette
c'est parti les guillaume pineau aussi
kita numérise plus d'anecdotes
il mène aussi je pense est censé nous
loue pas de casque mangold
moi je vais à pelleter à toutes mes
années de natation et tout le temps un
raconteur lui ces histoires des
attentats bas côté je me rappelle jabbes
on nous a mis diable qui est qui qui
demande aussi dit comme on sort le soir
avec tes le vendredi soir be j'ai juste
on est là tuez moi je vis la soirée avec
gilles labrosse couvrir mais j'ai juste
à dire parler lundi kim la radio qui me
la tende de sa perspective à long à vis
de comment il ya vu sur la pitié de
commandes comme tu dis il va emballer
et il va mettre de la chair autour de
l'histoire ce que tu veux dire là c'est
intéressant le mot perspective face
quand même sens où les histoires sur ma
page facebook où mr ils voient les gens
en vrai et ça repose dans le bain des
affaires dans ta vie c'est toujours il
sort il s'emporte sont autant dans la
tienne c'est juste que l'on se voit pas
ça d'un oeil et se sert même au risque
pourraient suivre une journée
le smo la nuit je vois tes créer des
affaires surtout basés au camp mais là
j'ai vu des trucs mais tous normal c'est
pas ton métier était gêné j'irai chez
vous dans j'irai nathan domaine depuis
je suis un gaulliste de pouvoir la même
affaire locale mais c'est vrai projet
une vie plus gros que les autres loin
d'adidas et jusque là voient
différemment que j'amène les petits
éléments dans ma tête
après sur un petit gars toujours le
ouvert ce qu'est ce qui est drôle c'est
que je ne vais vous qu'est ce qu'ils
foutent et de koltès muscle entrée
unique fêté situe à qui on est le muscle
créatif assez développés n'est pas de
créateurs la peinture c'est la même
chose il voit de quoi être comme ça et
dans une tirade d'analysé des couleurs
dans ce qui vous rend oui oui qui
imagine pas ce que tu veux c'est que va
transposer sur sa toile après c'est la
même affaire mais oui j'essaie de ne pas
trop y penser je fais confiance à mon
instinct et je me dis le flash va
arriver tous âges pas obligé d'être
obligé de marcher de même comme si je
revenais quelqu'un mais dans les galipes
les yeux et donc je ne regarde que tout
le monde pour monter des paquets 12 ans
alors je m'en tape avec mai mais dans
les débuts avec ma blonde s'était quand
même des notes souveraines mais ça a
donné que journée là s'il ya plein de
choses qui m'a lu mais on est en voyage
c'est fait qu'en voyage s'il veut pas
été vraiment comme des sorties ton
quotidien
sa vie est foutue compose avec ça est ce
que ta blonde et est le sujet de thé
numéro des fois non allez beaucoup dans
mes histoires sur facebook facebook j'ai
comme
volontairement et involontairement à la
fin volontairement la base créer une
espèce de toutes mes anecdotes sur
facebook sur ma page 3 fois sur 4 ça par
rapport à ma blonde et puis ça marche
très bien mais j'en partage les gens se
terrent croise les gens seraient
couverts dans la vie de couple
oui mais sur scène comme dans mon show
actuellement j'ai eu seulement une
histoire seulement par équipe comparable
ans puis c'est pas par rapport au fait
que le thé les gens vont se fait en dix
ans les humoristes bandolo dans le blanc
pense que si j'avais eu six histoires
par rapport à ma blonde
c'est juste que je me dis là ça a donné
dans mon show finalement après avoir
épuré tout ça il ya une histoire par
rapport à ma blonde mais mais ceux ci
c'est la personne avec qui je vis c'est
ce qu'on fait c'est sûr qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses qui l'entourent
là aussi que même qu'à spa avec elle
directement qui se passe du coup avec
quelqu'un d'autre même si est avec moi
c'est ce que souvent on va être inclus
dans l'histoire parce qu'elle devient
personnage fait qu'on peut dire des
lignes qui aideront à un meeting que je
vois concevoir ces faits que fait oui
mais se pose pas le but saretsky a dit
quelque chose puis l'a dit le lam et
boissons chaudes mais d'un partenaire
huawei la sas et je te dis c'est capoter
la legends qui il utilise le bon sketch
n'est pas le premier derrière schéma
blanc on faisait déjà partie j'ai loupé
gré je suis pas remporté de famille dans
belle famille la superstar qatari ou
dans le team en conférence de presse
c'est le fun mais active reste assez
couvert mais comme changement c'est
comme si je me sens mais avec les années
c'est moins pays mais dans les débuts
le fait que je termine ma blonde jeter 0
connu le t-shirt col d'azet mec tu y
voyons un peu comment ça va la fois que
je vois c'est aussi l'effet tva c'est
comme ça des images denses du monde
c'est comme le ta réussite
c'est ce qui certifie total 1 dans leurs
yeux
mais la grand messe à st trop tard bien
qu'estimé mais pour finir ça c'est un
matelot férid ben encore là ça me parle
pas du tout parce que je sais que les
gens sont pas mal mal intentionnés mais
quand que je commençais mon rodage des
gens je connais bien en plus haut et
kaka quand on va voir sa télé je veux
aller devoir ou car quand tu vois ta
dans une grande salle on va les devoirs
c'est quand le sous texte comme le ca
vaut pas la peine
mais quand maintenant je vois je vois
que tu es comme plus normal à travers
les vrais jumeaux rist loge la corderie
du temps mr peu c'est un peu encore une
faute si les autres trouve ça bon whisky
dans le train ouais mais je suis étonné
que celle du bonjour que jeudi matin
avec jean au groupe de moi je suis drôle
à callas et voilà je vois c'est beau je
pense afin d'avoir 45 à la dtc la barre
et car ces bonbonnes que cela blanc je
fais si cette météo des buts fox a du
bon boulot sexualité en donne carte
blanche
en fait quand on vient une fois de plus
à ranger encore le tournage est d'abord
être comment parler avant d'être mai
ça y est c'est un peu raté un rendez ma
vie ils sont seuls jeux ça va quand même
comme n'importe qui sont sur l'album
des fois il en tabarnak et mes vielles
enfin ils sont bien toute l'équipe le
pour de vraies leçons professionnels
sympathiquement si c'est merveilleux
pour de vrai ce sont vraiment des bonnes
personnes pour revenir à gramat deux
partenaires avaient bien mais ça garde
un peu à un chocolatier parce que maman
à chaud il se passe des choses dans
notre pays n'est pas foutu bloc béton
ben ouais des fois oui j'ai appris avec
le talent fou parce que moi puisque j'ai
fait beaucoup d'animations faire croire
8h06 à pornichet seulement d'improviser
d'envoyer dans fait que c'est mon
metteur en scène mon ami qui m'a dit le
faux soit c'est un choix je sais que tu
es bon tu fais quoi noir puis ça paye
des démons en impôts mais ça fait
toujours un petit dénivelé qatar vient
dans ton texte afin de niveler parce que
les publics ils savent le public le sait
pardon que tu viens de vivre un moment
là quand ils seront six pas écrit parce
que madame claudette le i7 le de
bécancour ci y est c'est fait tu vis de
coiffer qatar tombe dans ton texte
ces bons pareil parce que tu as un texte
rodez mais c'est sain du samedi clash
fait que ça sert pour ça sert pas
l'humoriste
mais il ya nour et l'animateur fait
clairement donné j'ai des sorties dans
mon show que je sais que je vais sortir
piste est assez rapide puis je reviens
pourquoi justement avoir cet effet là
parce que des fois je faisais deux
heures de show dont une heure et demie
du monde puis une demi heure du mot
aussi parce que ça riait qu'elle crée en
plus souvent encore plus qu'à mon texte
à cause d'un sentiment de
l'effervescence du moment que à steve
fallait pour la personne qui a parlé a
été bon et je gardais petite maman
systématiquement quitte fait que je
jouerai je prends cinq minutes ou
indivis net pida type cc
des secondes au dessin assez rapide
c'est vrai mais moi toute façon c'est
moi je tutoie le public leur parle
beaucoup étaient venus de tout le show
de votre empire est en folie de soi en
impression je te parle at war puis à toi
parce que je lui dis toi mais en général
je mon show il est très compact qui est
très rôdée ficelé serré c'est tout est
placé puis jetons obligé ça a été long
ça m'a pris 15 m 2 en mai après 2 h tous
obligés d'avouer que même en mettant en
scène avait raison joseph saint gelais
je salue d'ailleurs indiqué qu'ils lui
qui travaille à d'ailleurs avec avec le
josé depuis 15 ans vexé lui qui disait
kristofo fortement la la rigueur du show
du monde et j'avais un certain prix ils
viennent voir l'humoriste 100 colis ce
que tu sois bon pour animer c'est pas le
moment
puis amman et j'ai fait de regarder quoi
je me sens après les hits est comme
créer cet aspect de zonage tant par le
style de raison j'ai fait un show de
toutes parts à s'en sortir du texte
encore aujourd'hui on me meilleur choix
passe-temps concentre tout se suite tout
s'enchaînait pas de coupure pas de rien
pas des fois tu sors mais ça arrive des
fois que c'est moins payant parce que la
personne est gêné par ce cas tu réponds
pas trop au fait que mais ne trouvait
pas comme montre au public de pau
nécessairement réussi a dit sitôt fait
claude thibault switcher avec un autre
au pea a choqué en effet acheté rien à
donner les gens satis
il décolle de tons chauds sont moins
dans l'histoire cathare port après c'est
comme si ça fais en votre sein cinq
minutes on aurait pu sauver eux-mêmes
cas ça rit beaucoup
c'est pas grave christ aurait pu juste
faire ton show ça fait vraiment une
différence est maintenant d'être en
mesure de passer les deux ça fait
vraiment de grosses différences trouve
que mon show au prix de 5 koch juste en
étant dans ce soir je porte le chapeau
d'humoriste je suis humain et ceux ci
arrivent de quoi une porte ton mec
quelqu'un écrit il faut pas faire
semblant c'est le guerrier dans le texte
la faune la belle feuille sur la
mélanger
ces chèques tout le monde l'a entendu
c'est ce que je voyais aller chez ça
monte à faire aussi tentant de quoi en
avant est sûr que drogba n'avait ça fait
rire les dix autour de madame mais les
800 hommes ont perdu noyon et senlis
patients en avant et en arrière je pas
entendu le jeu pas dans l'histoire
cependant le monde s'est fait tout ça ça
fait décrocher le mans fait de rester
tight je trouve normal qu du moins ça
vaut la peine
tantôt tu disais c'est la question que
se posent peu importe c'est sa grille de
souza ripoull ouais c'est comme la
considération numéro un mais têtue
d'autres choses que tu veux passer après
ce après kiwi faux titre d'humoriste 200
remady et tant d'autres objectifs que ce
qu'elle va faire chaud c'est ce qu'a en
tant qu'humoriste homogène très bon moi
j'ai le privilège de prendre des marches
ou à travers le québec
ouais je me suis posé la question de
règle sèchement à passer pour acquis que
je me sens privilégié plutôt soul funky
et tabarouette je veux je veux montrer
que j'ai même de quoi dire mais c'est
comme je l'amenais comme je le voulais
feutrée paulo s'est pas conférencier
s'est pas on s'en prend à un moment où
on est en amour vous étiez j'ai même un
sujet d'avon chose quand même assez long
le sujet quand même noir puis quand
après 188 version j'ai fini par arriver
ainsi sept minutes que j'aime bien c'est
tout en humour mais mon but c'est que du
qatar pendant ton char après tu respires
sacristie où on a ri de telles affaires
pittham arnaquer non pas que raison mais
je trouve qu'en qui disait ça ou je sois
pas d'accord avec moi c'est pas grave
mais l'important c'est que j'ai trois
autres au numéro d'en voir show où c'est
un petit peu plus comme ça ça vote en
soirée parce que je l'entends la série
mais je le sais que ça va apporter
beaucoup plus long que la fin du
spectacle
c'est très gratifiant cinq ans ouais
white fossé important puis quand les
gens me le dise enfin oscille comme
légèrement henry puis j'ai pas aimé ça
qui te parle et à la fin je trouve ça
important puis je veux dire on n'est en
rien mais tu as raison c'est vrai qu'il
faut en parler puisque c'est ça pour moi
c'est comme moyen de différentes couches
dans mon show bougies je peux avoir un
gag de pénis plat vous dis jamais tu
vois l'eau dès qu'une demi-heure plus
tard tu vois je vois de plonger dans un
jeu dans un sujet plus noir tout en
étant quand même dans la
à la légèreté du moment ça j'aime ça
pour moi c'est un tour de force que je
voulais faire pour ça fait partie des
personnalités aussi blanches et noires
j'aime où jaillit mais je capable d'être
les juges capable d'être profond si fait
je voulais vraiment me seller de l'autre
pas parler plus souvent après les shows
display devrait passer dans mon champ a
très chaud j'ai repassé au pénis plein
qui plus est ajoutée qui pue ça les gens
qui sont toujours à stx et pas les gens
sont en fait les gens sont les gens sont
bien intentionnés huawei tout le temps
mais c'est pas toujours adéquats
l'annoncé survient ce soit plus la
contrebasse et c'est la seule borne wi
molding tech comme assez mauvais je leur
dis pas mais c'est ce cas c'est ce que
je vois pas dire vous pourrez acheter
kiplagat à la gag et l'eau puis encore
lost parce qu'ils savent pas tout le
temps qu'on met là dessus c'est dans la
tête
carbo et que je sois big bang il fait le
clown en avant afin que je vous disais
maintenant eu de la recherche l'un
derrière chaque phrase que je dis ça a
été pensée va leur demander aux banques
de payer un billet pour nous annoncer ça
ça fait que neuf fois sur dix c'est déjà
arrivé une fois comme si le fait ou un
monsieur mehdi 4 août
c'est pour ça que pour ça que j'aime
toutes les commentaires bon pas bon
constructif c'est pas grave tout le
monde un cerveau tout le monde est
intelligent dans les différents degrés
on s'entend mais tout le monde est
présent mentalement c'est pas à cause
qui était pas ce parcours se fait pas de
l'humour dans vie peut-être pas une
intelligence humoristique lundi pour ça
que je me suis quand même obligé mme
linda hunt des affaires même si dans
secondes je me dis je fais comme d'un
mandat écrit c'est sûr que non pour tel
et tel raison que je t'expliquerai pas
parce qu'on n'a pas de terre mais je
ressens une pareille qui me l'a dit mais
comme la fois que je me suis l'homme
avait dit dans un numéro que je fais
pipi dans le sol mais il m'avait dit que
ça comme un espèce de petit come back
avec le début mars que c'était vraiment
un endroit où j'ai fait instantanément
j'ai fait mes tables
sa séquelle sert-il d'avoir un oeil
extérieur titre à tous je vous disais
quand on est trop collé sur nos affaires
mois soit ma blonde mon gérant un
inconnu
je manque au lycée un commentaire c'est
un commentaire ce monsieur là il mais il
m'a fait réfléchir
puis la l'eau chaude après j'avais
ajouté le gars qui m'avait dit de faire
bien qu alice non seulement ça marchait
plus souvent qu'autrement il y avait une
claque qui suivait ce gag le fait que
c'est comme à chaque fois je pensais à
ce monsieur
ouais avec des fois non mais là je peux
pas trop dire et deux tiges point mort
et sur cinq ans aux listes et un cerveau
du ska pas de penser oui alors ben ouais
des moutons et petits moteurs dis moi tu
bois tu prends moi tout près souvent il
ya des diligences s'empêche de de passer
des commentaires par rapport à des
oeuvres d'or sous prétexte qu'ils
connaissent personne mais si tu
consommes une oeuvre d'art dont
l'opinion est quand même valable parce
que tu leur su marquer dans tous les cas
affectionne juste prend la peine de dire
quelque chose aussi nous devons le faire
les mettons pour le podcast le jargon
nécessairement une oeuvre d'art mais de
dire laisser des commentaires sur les
discussions du zoo dont les lip ça fait
un bout de chemin
mais quand un commentaire le oui ça
c'est vrai comme ça fait du sens
puis on s'en fou soit pas et spécialiste
en podcast à écouter une conversation
exactement j'ai entendu des gens parler
jazeera de réfléchir sur une quelque
chose dit il
puis après c'est à nous de savoir s'il
est d'accord de n'être pas d'accord mais
il a le savoir sur leurs exactions mais
donne donne au client c'est clair oui
totalement et puis en plus avec
l'accumulation sait si tout le monde la
donne c'est quand même en dessous des
podcasts justement la csu cela
commentaires comme auch posture mais si
vous lisez ces fois en dessous chacun de
vos pas de casse
vous allez vous regardez pas comme un
cri aux soins peut-être que c'est vrai
que diouf si les calculs faute et que
ces blacks et touba code rural ans est
important mais il est 5e
le point important à retenir mon petit
côté je trouve exactement ce que te dit
peu importe là une toile lorsque non moi
je suis trop sale est encore lire je
peux le dire qu'en voiture
moi j'en parle c'est boussamba mousse
pour ça que j'aime l'art moi j'aime
aller dans des musées avec ma blonde et
comme tout est à voyons cela en voiture
- me rappelle à juste à cause des trois
lignes
ça me rappelle manu je me suis fait
griffer barrages c'est quand puis avec
la le vert là ça me ramène donc enfin
dit non mais c'est plein à faire de même
que plus d'efforts sur une fripe mablas
on est phénomène comme tabarnak je suis
pas mais moi cette toile la dette du
profit mais que ce soit pour le fun
pareil pour animaux c'est tout est dans
la façon de dire si l'offre car je l'aï
oui j'aime juste pour son unique est ce
que tamponnant sont noirs c'est juste
qu'ils gosse de twilight eu le choc tu
l'as vécu plc moi je fais juste que je
viens au podcast maintenant de péage
d'occupation de geloux dessus un
jugement
ah ouais mais d'où le nom mais plus
intéressant que ce père saisit sa part
rapport d'une mission je comprends le
préjugé favorable
ouais alors c'est à vous de voir ce
qu'ils étaient fin d'émission
ceux qui jugent et musiciens qui
connaissait pas une émission c'est fou
la cécité de cette envie et non avec les
stars mais je sais
en fait notre booking pour les podcasts
si on écrit on essaie d'écrire
vraiment on essaiera de ses parents même
si des fois on a des refus puis ça peut
très possiblement être ceux qui jouent
un rôle de team parce que c'est
certainement paul nos côtes d'écouté
parce que probablement tout le monde
dirait oui c'est sauf que c'est sûrement
ce qui joue un rôle puis file copie les
côtes d'écouté sont bonnes mais je pense
humblement que le contenu est bon aussi
pour les bonnes discussions texte
intéressant et meilleur show ces lettres
ces lettres c'est moi je conçois
horrible la prévention du suicide a
changé mais j'avais toujours là être
humain avec l'humoriste c'est super
important
mais moi j'ai même des amis là que je
prend nécessairement fin de leur rhume
au cd fois que je les aime mais je me
dis je vais voir leur show parce que
c'est un ami mais je sais que c'est le
coin où selon lui ou elle qui me fait le
plus rire mais comme un être humain
tabarnak ce bon mot rien que je parle à
tous les jours c'est faux faut faire la
part des choses s'étaient pas tu étais
pas péage de dénoncer cdph qui a fait
d'un moment dans sa vie aux dés c'est
terminé tourner la page parce gorée club
de saintes
c'est la même chose là j'essaie toujours
de d'enlever cette étiquette lahoud et
de jugement le 6 ou 10 fois à telle
personne assise gosse je sais pas elle
est écoute pas ça aux deux hommes baho
je sais quoi mais mais je connais pas le
homard vous qui gosse aux militaires il
ya d'autres choses qu'on connaît pas
plus je deviens un budget c'est un bon
je connais un peu les dessous de
commence pas facile la vie était qu un
score similaire dans maison en forme et
ça se peut qu'au moment donné tu m'as tu
as dit de la merde août et bah écoutez
je veux dire ta peau véhicules été fixée
pour ce jeu c'est que le jugement mais
j'essaie d'être loin de tout ça pour
toujours mais tout comme tout exemple
c'est qu'un maigre et dj mehdi
j'enregistre studio de thq gold le godet
à ne pas faire c'est qu'on s'est
rencontrés la veille du super six
je trouve ça l'fun puis au pays durant
contre la personne qui passe c'est ce
que je croisais dans des accords tout ce
qu'il disait
tabarnak and co pour moi ce sera mieux
au moins t'es sûr exact puis puis juste
pour finir source qui visitait on avait
envoyé déjà une invitation à patrick
senécal c'est l'otan qui avait créé son
agence était comme non c'est trop occupé
pour l'instant c'est trop occupé pour
l'instant comme si comme pour dire non
surtout qu at il dit
la date de ses voeux le recevoir quand
il veut il est trop occupé pour
l'instant dans ok que l'on sait c'est
good puis là après ce sont ces son fils
qui avait écouté l'émission qui écouter
le podcast et qu'on fait là pas faux si
je te dis c'est lorsque tu penses y est
pas comme tu penses et puis finalement
leur subi c'est au début on se met à
parler plomb tombe rapidement j'en parle
de cinéma du cinéma expérimental on
parle littérature on parle de cépie
genre on est bonne ce qui est étonnant
c'est qu'ils ont illuminé le jeu après
bakassi fait comme moi mais je
m'attendais vraiment on s'entendait pas
quelqu'un de télé réalité comme on
s'attend personne là-bas vraiment qui
comme sa palette mais c'est ce qu'il
faut c'est des bonnes personnes de télé
réalité comme mon sapin
on s'attend ce dacquois c'est quoi la
c'est quoi la définition de contrat ce
qui veut dire le mot mais fumer mais
quand on lit ce type de peau peut pas
traiter son nom faute à le valider avant
peut pas dire non du revers de la main
mais c'est une belle leçon de vie pour
lui encore plus niveau 2 parce que c'est
son fils saison fut l'élève de la
semaine le jugement qui risque de vous
revoir tous ces malades c'est qu'en plus
lui avait écrit un livre qui comme qui
tourne autour de la télé réalité le
lycée camille causse critiques sur
seulles et effectueront brown sa
réticence à l'idée mais mais j'étais
contente que qui coûte son futur et nuit
son lit d'après le brûlé brûlé sais que
je le suis a plaidé
mais pas touche à la missa à deux bons
lagrave west ham et non mais c'est bon
mais j'allais revenir là dessus de ses
souliers des vidéos fia on va parler
pendant cinq heures d'affilée
enfin un jeu il fallait pour l'expert
d'un crayon rapidement pourrait créer
pour m mais je pense qu'ils obligent les
charges fait juste échapper stylo ils
m'ont médecin d'argent au sketch la
seule le jargon de la blanche comme
habitude le mahb landes
oui oui g au vert oui les charger votre
gauche le ster et elle est enfin là pour
elle j'ai parlé mais même les gens après
les shows des fois c'est dix fois le 1 m
puis sa femme le plein m'arrive à dire
un mot s'y installe à telle place du
poteau il va mettre ça dans son sketch
l'affect marine dit qu'elle est ici
c'est tellement un peu d'informations il
arrête je trouve ça tellement comme un
espèce de vraiment un gap générationnel
de j'ai l'impression du deuxième niveau
là si on ouvre comme la compréhension du
deuxième niveau là parce qu'on a comme
grandi dans des temps de l'humour un peu
un peu deuxième niveau justement de la
cepi puis est vraiment un gars mettons
mettons que les gens choisissent en
montant peut-être le tc deuxième niveau
là j'ai comme l'impression qu'ils posent
100% l'outil non parce que
en plus c'est comme si je le dis c'est
nous autres applis sont élevées avec des
pleins de maurice au québec par
finalement nourrit de pas juste des
humoristes humour de série d'humour de
tout notamment évidemment pas connu
grand-chose humoristiquement parlant il
y avait son niveau des effectifs et que
ses fils harry potter exact que c'est
comme pisser c'est pourtant ces jeunes
c'est juste un code d'humour donc on
possède que certaines générations pas
cette pole mais c'est ça qui est beau
moi j'ai de la chance je dirais pas
voulu mon humour helmand et moi je
passais certes 77 même si des fois je
cassais grinçant 717 ouais ça que salut
bonjour dire que salut bonjour
5 61 10 mai à cause d'eux des podcasts
des enfants de même des fois j'ai 25 ans
je faisais codjia vrai qu'avant j'ai
plein de puis moi de voir du monde comme
rire en même temps
trois générations sur un gag ça me fait
bander psychologiquement parlant on
sentait des fois j'ai une sainte sara
baras fait un délai les gens se parlent
se sky pastilles en australie le tarab
sac à six sa série péter graefe un peu
je te laisse l'image de m mais j'aime
aussi faire rire les
les millénium aussi fait rire les 38 ans
et protège il ya des gars que je sais
qu'ils sont plus de niche et puis je les
laisse là je me dis qu'il reste
peut-être que je 125 personnes qui vont
là rires subissant mais il vaut en rire
encore liste parce que c'est une
référence extrêmement précise ça me fait
rire le faire c'est fait que j'aime
j'aime jouer toutes les cordes puis me
promener dans différentes sphères
puis prenant que ton style se prête
aussi plus insulter tout le monde peut
s'associer à une bonne histoire qui est
racontée le tir pour reprendre l'exemple
de yannick ça se peut qu'il y en ait qui
est du monde conquis face qui
comprennent pas ce qui se passe c'est
tout raconte une job ça va être drôle
soumettent à un sac concerns about
tabarnak c'est vrai tu as well as a
service à face aussi qu'un petit joueur
savoir lors du jugement mais c'est juste
que je rapporte des faits mais quand tu
pars maintenant je te regarde région qui
risque quand tu joues en région mary
souvent qu'autrement au lait deuxième
degré ils vont passer dans le vide où
ils vont où ils vont faire des robots
celio soudainement ils vont oublier la
crise touche aux mots si on a
l'impression est avec moi depuis le
début
reste avec moi c'est ce parcours ce que
change de green bay a annoncé sa fille
ce qu'un petit jard vient justement
d'une tournée dans l'est du québec bien
ce soir particulièrement genre a été
dans le show j'ai fait leur la gangue
lieu on va se parler lola le papa et en
aval c'est j'ai fait j'ai sorti un bon
deux minutes de christ on sentait depuis
la touche tomber dans l'ironie de
thiviers tabarnak
j'ai même accusé il fait là je suis dit
t'es pas rennes m'a regardé petit dit
voyons tabarnak à ce qui se passe ce
type est en fait ironique images faisant
complètement l'un vertes qu'est ce que
je pensais je disais merci aux gens qui
ont fait des eaux pas c'est vrai ce que
je dis je le pense pas aux vrais c pa du
monde vous avez bien fait de port et
avoue marc placé en estie les cinq qui
ont ri en avant un magasin des crises de
judo vous autres cas au luxembourg vodka
c'est quoi leur vous avez passé à ce que
je fais c'est les autres il ya encore
plus parce qu'ils comprennent bien sûr
les eaux d'été comme le regard des
autres un mélange de huawei et puis mais
là il n'ya ici tu sais puis là j'ai
juste fini en disant oui merci pour ça
vous êtes fin c'est comme ça qu'on
reconnaît les vrais main
d'applaudissements j'ai continué j'ai
continué moi même je te pas tout à fait
sûr de passer sa main quand on lire
jusqu'à la fin du show s'aérer d'un
bonheur le ganil mai puis le gode la
salle multi tabarnak assez spécial
intervention te fait plutôt bien fait
les a fait sortir de leur coquille et
parce que c'est la cee arnaque j'aime ça
il a fallu je m'arrête parce que là
c'est trop bien d'être trop de oro sur
des gags même tennessee des fois il ya
des gars que je peux comprendre sa part
le plus serré
mais la tam arnaque je te dise tu es
vraiment léger mais non mais non c'est
bien si je crève moment la déconne
tu sais bien que cela ne fasse par
rapport à ce qu'est ce que je viens de
dire ceci que j'allais pour ce que j'en
sais pas ce que c'est vraiment spécial
mais je sais il y en a des fois qu'ils
vont changer des numéros qui vont y
aller plus curieux plus vulgaire c'est
correct parce que c'est vrai que ça
marche on va se le dise ça fonctionne
est identiquement sacré avec la chine
dans sa phase à 6 à stable si et cuisses
mais je me dis j'ai pas de numéro de
même nécessairement dans le show puisque
je te présente c'est mon show le colis
ce nom sam médecin brillant tabarnak
je comprends que ce qu'on ressent
peut-être moins du mot on n'a pas la
même réalité c'est plus des travailleurs
je comprends mais c'est pas vrai sera
pas capable hostile et d'embarquer dans
le show c'est pas vrai puis quitte à
faire une intervention de minutes qu'ils
ont on va aller chercher on va reculer
pour prendre un dali ça me dérange pas
mais on voit syntoniser je résume à
peut-être même le faire avant parce
qu'il a peu près une demi heure au chaud
mais la dernière demi heure c'est comme
un changement de cap qui risque là là là
on était là oui semble avoir un talent
pour mac parce que tu as commencé
vraiment rien à faire sur mais à lire le
monde le diamant bing gdg des défauts
mais sauf au football donne moi c'est
juste un bon ben ça y est les gens le
public pour ça moi j'aime pas les voir y
en a qui aimeraient avoir la salle est
quand même éclairé ok vous j'aime pas
les voir parce que tu t'es pas trop
attention à la réaction
non parce que je touche aux affaires
personnelles les lumières allumées
quand il fait noir tu profites de plus
en plus dans ta bulle
si t'as plus libre je trouve de rire ou
de pleurer ou de vivre une émotion 2 1
puis 2 2 ça me permet encore plus de
filets rectif défilent au sont plus qu'à
lui
ouais film avant de rentrer en scène
j'écoute un peu en vo sur soi c'est pas
beaucoup à se voir sa peine pour faire
asseoir sa part très fort le message
maison madame messieurs bons spectacles
intimes programme non picasa dit bon
spectacle n'ya pas d'applaudissements
ils étudient ou sawat énergie que ça va
être un bon début
georges étienne faut que j'analyse tout
cela avant avant même que jean habert
que j'analyse toutes les réactions
puis
j'ai pas première partie pour parce que
j'aime quand c'est la glace on dirait
que vu que j'ai commencé de même aussi
en animant des trucs puis j'avais 18 ou
19 ans au quai halot la gagne 3 points
elle d'en face pour gêner mon mariage
pendant que ma 12e titre de d3 de la
folie dit à trop du matin
j'aime mais j'en ai eu une fois pierre
yves roy desmarais j'avais davidbourque
agents et des bus qui passait avec 4
levac jean pierre yves roy desmarais qui
faisait déjà petits seins si crise du
bois est incroyable était vraiment en
bon là puis je l'écoutais ça riait
c'était merveilleux
il est à chaud quand j'arrivais tout
accord j'adorerais ça mais j'aime mieux
encore plus arriver à frites surtout que
je pense qu'on y perd connu fait que la
gms a encore plus arrivé pour moi même
briser la glace et j'ai même chose pour
ça que finalement j'ai pris la décision
que j'allais pas avoir demandé à partie
mais juste un choix très personnel mais
mais c'est jamais sauvé j'ai brisé la
glace tout de suite laurier-station une
ville à la campagne pendant québec
arrive alors là c'est comme si j'arrive
pas exactement ça se prend bien pour
pousser aussi le basket a offert un
petit peu sortir andré parleboscq
anciennement y avait pas que tu étais le
leti cody village qui fait toutes les
parties dans le fond mais pas tant
laurier non parce qu'il ya deux mois
fait des parents sont séparés quand je
parle de région s'est beaucoup chez ma
mère angélique est un village voisin qui
de laurier-station qu'il ya aussi la
sortie avant canaris n'ont rien lui on
est plus en région encore huawei en dix
minutes plus loin l'espace a
l'impression qu'ils avaient roulé vite
heures dans le fond dans le bois bon
loris plus banlieue si on veut lutter
contre des russes ont collé puisse plus
vilaj vilaj à jeudi chez ma mère serment
les râles c'était vraiment quand je
parle de région je pense beaucoup chez
ma mère mais mais moi j'ai comme je
partis la maison à 16 ans j'ai étudié
deux embauches et nous tue à sainte foy
ou à lévis moi je voulais aller plus
loin jusqu'à la saint georges de beauce
au cégep beauce appalaches
on a par direct par souvent lévis à une
fois tu as voyages
chacun apporte ses puits pas que t'es
pas bien chez nous des parents non mais
je voulais vivre suite comment allait
bien fait qu à passer à 1 go qui m'a vu
kim à engager pour une compagnie qui
couvrait la région de la beauce spi
québec fait que j'ai autant joué dans le
fond lauriers qui lui fait le festival
quelques festivals la bonne mais non pas
vraiment mais mais j'ai fait les duos
isabelle forget in incroyablement parce
que moi je pouvais être au château
frontenac 1 vendredi soir à nîmes un
mariage le samedi soir est à djeddah
bois des grognons à beauceville mon
party de bureau en se baladant cri des
mouettes apprend de tout les styles -
c'est haute voix et ses formateurs ouais
c'est ça c'est formateur puis c'est sûr
que ça reste avec toi encore maintenant
ah bah oui bah oui exactement quand on
parle d' analyse du public
10 - là que tu es les clichés de cap
d'ariel du midi 3 aussi j'aurais pu
comme physiquement tête un petit odeurs
parce que des infirmiers
mon beau père était fermé et images est
élevé sur une ferme le débit
heureusement il prenait sa douche
toujours millions en notes étaient du
coup moins cette ambiance loft comme un
cri asseoir sa voiture puisse content
d'être là
si c'est comme ça que tu vis mais un
colissimo gens embarquent dans ton monde
à soir puis c'est ça que savoir être
puis des fois c'était pour mieux l'aider
fois québec lé système ainsi william des
fosses à lèvres glissement ballon c'est
ça que les joueurs
la voiture un peu plus calmes et lyon un
peu plus corporate c'est un médium avec
les avec les gens de la place mais je me
mets à les agacer ça c'est kas qui me
permettait de gagner des points parce
que je les agace est que le micro devant
le mans un pur aph
j'avais calleri parce que je les avais
saiz et le naseau yriel les autres à
regarder à qui le transmettra
moi ça me faisait capoter de voir à quel
point à 5 heures avant le super souvient
me voir quasiment parlant à la française
camille l'ennemi et nice ce soir je
viens de le réduire à ce titre god is
dying de saint tabarnak du bois de la
travail
salamé a capoté de mon départ j'ai
autant de fans avec le goca cravate
cloud go qui a arrêté l'école
un huitième à nico midi
harper a fermé son passé de deux
histoires merveilleuses si on va voir
autant de plaisir tous cachés dans le
monde je connais pas personne je leur ai
pas parlé
fox pour ça que j'aime ça faisait déjà
j'aime avoir la veille de la foule puis
cassé noir ça me permet encore plus de
jeux trouve de deux filets le moment
comme ça me permet de me concentrer plus
sur le ressenti
parce que quand l'apparence et polis ils
régissent les réactions les réactions
ouais ça va être les mêmes pour tout le
monde peu importe ta classe sociale peu
importe l'endroit exact et aux autres
c'était dans le noir petit jules
exactement le mot c'est du monde battus
est douce et on va réussir à l'isq
rejoindre puis au père n'en puis au ps
pas grave
séoul a sorti puis en plein d'eau j'ai
eu cette réflexion la loggia on est un
mois j'étais un mariage de nos amis puis
puis comme dans un mariage il faut que
la célébration et fait le super fini que
ce dj tout le monde et sur le partage la
même façon entre des mafieux de 60 ans
le père de la mariée qui sur le
dancefloor avec le cousin exprime dit
oui derrière les trucs tout le monde
danse sur la même tourner deux écoles
qui date du début des années 2000 tout
le monde est dans ma zone
plus tu dis que mon art à l'hôtel
pendant six mois c'est ce monde il est
content c'est quoi ta vie
chris avoir du fun tout le monde d'avoir
fourni la même façon ouais peu importe
qu'on me tue fait par année pour importe
ta [ __ ] dans une faute king commune au
fin fond de chypre au couer oubaita un
condo d'antan new york
on sent qu il est un exemple bombe à ces
mariages c'est que ce mets ma partie
préférée quand ça commence a souligné
löw les gens se délivre de leurs
réglages social soudainement de bien
plus que la boisson car ben oui mais
c'est baudoin oui mais à tous les sites
ou les papas linceul et monsieur louis
l'émotion surtout poignet puis la
famille dans ce domaine sur plancher de
danse avec leur manière ce type c'est
l'fun jusqu'à que son taux jamais vus de
même j'ai élevé mes gilles
une fois notre plus beau mariage
mais oui maison les api moi j'ai pas
vécu un mariage où est-ce qu'ils aient
eu une situation plateau d'un mariage au
sens où tout les mariages dans lesquels
mais peut-être quelques chanceux ou
simplement de toutes les images dans
lesquelles je suis allé tout le monde
était là pour une raison
c'est le batteur elles ont célébré
l'amour des mariés faire le party je
trouve qu'il ya quelque chose qui réunit
tout le monde ma réaction n'est souvent
individualiste puis j'en fais partie on
est beaucoup de nos pensées nos affaires
dit ce qui est bien qu liste un mariage
c'est ce qui fait c'est ce qui fait la
beauté de la chose c'est que quand tu
débarques là à 3 heures d'après midi
avant la l'église mettant tout le monde
est armé mais on dirait que tout le
monde porte le même chandail mais je
fais des métaphores doc et j'ai bloqué
200 voix d'or qui j'ai joué à tabac donc
non je trouve que tout le monde est là
où les maris on est là pour eux
à wattrelos phone aujourd'hui on est
enfant veut tous créent la monnaie aux
hommes de personnes là qu'on aime on
arrêtait qui coûtait le cousin et
soudainement on se met ça c'est ma jose
alors que normalement mes petits-enfants
si je trouve que ses poursuivants qui
accueille en panne de métro des fois
quasiment content que quand ça dure
longtemps
je me dis crise on va se mettre sous la
main y avaient leur bail tomatis
maybelline
je trouve ça plate que ça bloque parce
que j'arrive l'hôpital monod voulait le
voir mon mari était plus de
compréhension histoire du tna josip cité
quand la stib ont fait cinq minutes je
la juge l'a tabarnak pascal payet encore
lire cet effet finalement si tu manges
osé parce que le mes trois reports
profites tu réalises que madame la
raison tabarnak dead by pis si ça se
trouve encore plus bas et qu'elle met ça
m'arrivait sa situation
c'était que trouve ça l'fun de des fois
que
caen sort la taille du cul qui expliqua
on est capable de laisser tomber des
humains vraiment j'ai c'est ce que
j'aime le plus je pense être je suis
toute petite anecdote cocasse de mariage
voilà doivent être un christ rouge en
est un que j'ai rencontré à des
squelettes dans le placard avec patrice
l'écuyer à l'ajout cas alors vous avez
une approche de la cote a baissé chez
vous cela a causé assez catastrophique
c'est un mariage justement en beauce
puis en étant offert en fin de la
veillée ça soit investi la mariée est
parti avec cette somme de filles autres
aléas d'un classique là où sont allumés
foot - quote tu là il réajuste la mariée
ce plancher de danse avec une dizaine de
ses charmes de go bien le mot j'ai fait
comme alaska ou relative avec l'auteur
commence comme un défaut il faut comme
ça arrête pilote anglais mais oui aux
deux championnes mon ami guillaume et
sophie noël il est chaud me pong lemarié
oui le marié venco ida il faut jouer une
coupe plus c'est un peu de ma faute
parce que moi c'est le moi j'étais pas
là l'après midi je n'ai pas là l'église
le cemea dans l'après midi à l'église y
avait fait il y avait versé dans un vase
ce qu'on appelle les sables de l'amour
c'est legault verts semblent bleus la
fidh sable rose qui s'entremêlent dans
le vin estime à soustons foyer puis tu
t'en actrice main en avant c'est comme
ça que ça fonctionne mais moi je n'avais
pas que le val à la flèche avec
christelle ça ressemble de loin ça
semble encore ouverte la question de
loin sa main une coupe pour ce qu'il a
fait c'est moi je suis encore le type de
match que je sais pas vous qui ont fait
ça dans l'église où je passe une
décoration de table ce qui est nouveau
c'est d'y soigner des quotas bon c'est
encore lire ni vont acheter toute façon
évidemment ce qui devait arriver arrive
au échappe leva aux estompe sur l'épaule
d'un go tombe à terre parce ça éclate en
bio sens
je cacherai pas que ça éclate et on sent
que ça a fait me suis dit inter sa part
la dette ici aux prestations solo un
plastique sonne le cristal c'est ben
carolis et laulala marié revient là
marié revient voit son écoute là comme
dans un film
ce camp là kring se pilote à battre son
mari sont madame leuthard rappelle la
musique joue encore dans le fond de la
ruelle de losers encore dix dates à plat
est là
la csp finissent en l'annonçant son nom
j'adore tout ce que tu penses que tu dis
est impossible se raconte comme dans un
film
je n'ai vécu je sais une fois par contre
sur une centaine de mariani avait rendu
2 heures du matin oya proches voisins
c'est la catastrophe
el al en lève le genre de match c'est la
goutte qui fait déborder le vase
j'avais envie d une api de ben arous
même s'ils ont fermé ma gueule arrêté
suis là at on idée de pause il ya accord
lycée sanguin accord au lycée sans aucun
puis le froid ouais légèrement oui
c'était bien tassés c'est la goutte qui
fait déborder wanda fêtera son mariage
puis le vase étant une grotte de
déborder dit oui je le veux d'antonin
moi c'est ce que je disais à mon dj qui
ont démonté les caisses de son parent
cela elle accueilli ce sens qu à tout le
monde que jal hôtels tout le monde est
parti dans un silence de mort tout est
rentré dans différents étages plus
notons démonter c'est le cas de l'hôtel
devenus illégaux on ferme la musique
puis motard d'un jour les effets des
caisses de son jeu un bon dj est pour
vous c'est super réactivant boissons
puis que dans une heure ou demain matin
avant rire ou soit qu'on ait menti peu
pauvre en actions dite a créé samarie
tabarnak c'est bon ça veut dire c'est la
goutte est pas là quelque chose à ce que
je me suis dit en même temps c'est moi
qui a fait six mois que je suis dans ce
sketch je me suis finalement deux
semaines plus tard la mère de la mariée
me rejoint le rejoint voilà lui doit
deux mais quatre comédies le oui je suis
la mère d'isabelle s'appelle isabelle se
sont fait la malle zaber et montrouge
chimiques une sur la corde raide eu une
bonne contraction du sphincter le
territoire froid dans le dos c'est
l'enfant avait juste asie merci je dis
quoi
l'alarmé je pars pas ce qui s'est passé
là-bas aussi
c'est vrai que ça marrant mais il y en
avoir en bout de ligne on sait écrire
sur ma fille fait deux ans que tu es
dans une relation toxique
on n'était pas capable de son job puis
quand ça glisse aussi pour que ça marche
parce qu'il avait su que le gauche s'est
défendu en disant que l'animateur qui me
disent prendre le vent au stif et clust
com appelé pour me dire c'est bien
correct ça a pris soin pour que sa fille
fait savoir m la very good et se sentent
comme marie on le voit forcée à leur
mort ils sont séparés à leur mariage le
soir du mariage là dessus j'imagine de
suite tu m'aides les mêmes dans un
mariage puisse apprendre qu'une histoire
comme ce soit explose de paris ce matin
mais il y avait le sourire à tout le
monde de se rendre compte de chuck bass
et sur une relation taxi d'où la phrase
aux guerriers qui arrivent pour y est
mais tant mieux tant mieux pour elle
pour vous une demi heure mais j'ai
trouvé tour de madame deux semaines je
pense qu'en séries spéciales
je pars responsables de la la réaction
de la réaction ou de leur historique de
coupe mais jusqu à ma portée mais en
bout de ligne
merci mais ces grosses marques année
d'après afin que ceux ci passent ces
plates
non mais là tels que des politiques à
travers l'histoire est content des
derbys télésites ans que tu racontes là
trail que tu as fait des corps popito
mariage c'est exactement ce que je que
je fais puisque j'ai fait en musique
aussi
ollier fil à deux autres matin puis ça
c'est la classe des terrasses région va
jouer du coderc août
des fois tu arrives en faisant haye a
rejeté la gagne la gagne de pharmacie
mettons des 6000 genre ça s'abroge des
soins et les pharmaciens sont capables d
fois ci comme python choi orascom
d'accord les amarres c'est vrai que ça
des fois c'est un avantage c'est tantôt
jeudi à 10 fois en région dès fois
audrey deuxième degré en moins vite
toutefois pas demandé mon gars de région
souvent non c'est parce qu'un mariage
c'est possible et 4 en histoire mais
c'est juste qu'on joue triple au final
sept pilotes à mon kit de son kit health
effects pileux et autres voulaient
construire dans ces paquets le dire ces
termes et une playlist après les autres
on aller dans mon char une sieste on
attendait deux heures puis après ça on
aide les monticules de son dès qu'on les
aime c'est que jouer enfin dans mon char
siglé au genre si on attend on attend
deux ans qu'est la soirée finesti l'aca
dans sa danse plus on gagne le marié
cécile chaume la mariée puis c'est comme
des filles tipsa dans un spi à mener
voilà marié sortir avec une de ses amies
sont des banquets et jean puis deux
trois minutes après marié à ça je suis
sûr que c'est qu'ils font plus ce chèque
la marive son ami ils vont subir la
tempête
deux filles à pleine bouche on peut se
faire mais cameron c'est fini on va
mettre une photo mg à pleine bouche si
le board l'attend l'opt in my revenge
automne dans charlie lumières fermées ne
voit pas laisser tomber là c'est comme
si de rien n'était qui l'eu
en tout cas il y en as l'agent de samedi
avait pu aller voir la mariée le canton
qu'athènes chance pour ce n'est pas un
échec patent banque aurait apprécié au
fait c'était si tu vois se croise aussi
des reptiles donner l'enveloppé
l'acclament année je voi 800 d'attentes
puis ça vaut vraiment pisser dans le
bourg était un peu plus loin avec le je
vais dire à l'intercepter king va
revenir je n'ai pas de stress mais
c'était un chèque pas loin au menu les
tableaux non mais je le tiens qui était
garé des piscines pour l'intercepter
usaï baldwin à la nappe et si vous êtes
vraiment bon apparemment belles
sonneries killer on se retourne puis on
voit nom de sa femme sur le banc de
l'attentât seraient en pleine bouche
l'envoi ce puis le lait dont le vu le
lanceur garde lima regarde les faits
ainsi que tu vois là c'est ma femme puis
le jeu fait citer aucun nom
ok j'ai rien dis je vais à du kof a
qu'un pas merci pied bon c'est pas le
chèque ne postera le chiac s'ils
exigeaient large poche et pas trop plu
sera triplée ce matin là au sport puis
la pression les avis ils sont sortis
d'attenté les deux qui sont allés plus
loin se parler le boys band of qu'ils
sont par les 15 minutes le sert pas
d'appeler les amis allez voir qu'est ce
qui se passe plus près 15 minutes sept
cols bleus
bon ils s'entendent en attendant ces
cinq minutes dit mariage dit un temps je
sais pas la fierté c'était pas évident a
déçu mais elle va pas l'art sur pie mais
là dessus ouais ça arrive le soir de son
mariage la république
mais dans notre vie on a comme un qu est
ce que j accepte le fait que si une
sororité de cet article mais isabelle
s'est remarié mais une autre site il est
des gens des gens de la place à laval où
est ce qu'il n'ya point de salut n'est
coté de l'autre il ya un mariage dans
chaque sens je peux ce genre de plat ou
et il y en a partout parce que j'ai un
ami qui jouait dans un mariage dans une
salle puis à un mariage la salle à côté
tant pis il dit il y était le sup était
pas fini que le mariage est annulé
ben voilà pis le dise ça s'est su dire
en soirée qui avait trompé la ocz potro
puis la fin de la soirée c'était les
deux familles les deux par des familles
qui s'engueulaient ce rookie qu'elle est
payée mariage c'est comme ça ouah alors
cessons couleurs imaginez justement
l'élément qui fonçe
comme tous les jours encore
professionnellement j'ai encore des amis
hautala flanc pour de vrai c'est un
métier où je les fait un bond de sa me
former mais si j'arrête pas continuer à
faire cela
j'en ai pour continuer ses métiers c'est
vrai métier mais c'est aussi quelles
étaient ses soucis sur le voyage de
philippe il crée nager stopped à fossoy
parce que ces gens là paf c'est une
journée 14 heures arrive le matin par
mois et ça puisse potable c'est payant
il faut vraiment de quoi passer de
laboratoires adwya assiatou g2a dj le
droit parce que c'est mon cas mais je
voulais qu un garde est venu ici sur le
podcast de jean te dis une des choses
qui m'a fait le plus rire la dernière
année parce que jay disait que toi tu
étais déjà ram parler de la même façon à
tous le monde peu importe c'est qu'ils
le tout est dit
si obama était devant moi je le sais
qu'un swaps cds fois de nous parler
après les chaussées instagram y en a qui
m'écrit ps whif d'abba c'est juste ça ah
ouais mais tellement bon parce qu'il
sait de longue parenthèse pour l'estrie
pourquoi je trouve sympa quand je t'ai à
l'université on n'avait jamais en cours
de création littéraire ou est ce qu a
mené on avait un exercice fallait écrire
deux pages fallait humaniser une
personnalité connue ou célèbres puis la
l'épreuve avait donné l'exemple de
gandhi qui des fois buvait sa piste pour
montrer qu'ils étaient pilotés fait
c'était comme de rendre le personnage
qu'on a vraiment en haute estime juste
de le rabaisser au au stade sud de tout
le monde l'a dit ça c'est tellement bon
comme image parce que
même petits mouchoirs
oui mais c'est ça la planète que des
fois il obtient pas du wef de battre les
filles aussi les faits aussi j'essaie de
j'essaie de varier
une wave ii plateaux mais je trouvais ça
tellement je trouve je trouve tellement
que c'est au delà de gamme puis de la
façon dont tu le dis à quel point c'est
une réflexion qui qui me rejoindre qui
fait du sens
les personnes ou finale qui est au
dessus des de quelqu'un d'autre
mais oui c'est vrai ce que tu dis tantôt
critique mais plutôt secondaire utile
pdg de la compagnie
voilà c'est un appareil peut douter pas
intimider par les titres pas quoi que ce
soit non non non non moi je sais pas ce
que je trouve que l'important c'est de
se respecter
comment comment comment tu peux te
respecter dans la vie c'est en étant
fière de toi même tu sais quand moi je
me dis je serai jamais personne plus
haut que moi puis moi je suis jamais plu
aux personnes
c'est ce style d'égalité la vie pour ça
oui la webcam carrément mais ce festival
téléphone les jambes raides show là ils
vont même jusqu'à vous voyez des fois
d'être une fois j'ai cinq son accent
stress est un petit peu parlé huawei
pour ce spécial de rencontrer des gens à
titre posthume connaît beau mais juste
en deçà de ce parti ne connais pas assez
je sais juste qu'ils me connaissent est
là tuez-le lejdd fois encore les esprits
si tu veux on est candidat on est
vraiment plus pareil quand on sait juste
sur ses pieds ces puits moi aussi
c'est comme on m'attend je pense à son
capitaine je suis rom intimidés dans la
vie si je le voyais bon c'est sûr mais
rapidement je redescendrai mai mais je
sais qu'en janvier avec lui quand même
parce que je suis je connais pas
personnellement mais j'ai entendu parler
des amis qui apparemment sont bâties
sans permis mais c'est vraiment je suis
promené ce que tu dis c'est vrai que ça
c'est juste qu'on se connaît pas puis je
les comprends parce que moi aussi at-il
crosby je le connais pas et par avoir
tout ce qui est accompli mais aussi sa
rigueur au travail
moussa vient me chercher fait normal je
le regarde un peu de monde le regarde un
peu dangereux mais en bout de ligne je
sais je sais si rapidement il serait de
mardan trois minutes à taberna qui
prendrait le banc parce que je crois pas
non je peux pas idolâtrer quelqu'un qui
est une marque qui est humainement me
plaît pas c'est comme cela que ça
passerait pas pour ça que pour ça que
j'aime les gens qui ont un statut de
connu public m'attend mais qui sont très
terre-à-terre oui moi c'est mon fils et
mon but aussi le t2t comme les affaires
vont bien de plus en plus connu sous sol
fans mais à ce titre je veux pas perdre
ce genre de grande auberge pas tellement
entouré des bonnes personnes la famille
aussi tu pense pas que ça va arriver
mais en fait je veux te dis que ça
arrivera jamais parce que j'entends ma
mère jamais mais non mais je trouve ça
important c'est de plus alors je sais
comme tantôt de certains autres
affichent une parenthèse sur qu'est ce
qu'on a dit par rapport à patrick
senécal petit comme si ce sont son
gérant bâton visant mais il est bien
occupé c'est moi des fois le des fois
quand on est occupé pour vrai mon
général des fois il me dira t-il mais
c'est la date de ton choix
alors doit-on choix puis des fois je
sais qu'on abat d'abord le non non non
répond pas quand je suis vraiment occupé
parce que christophe le mot complet je
voyais écrit un petit mot je vois écrit
un petit mot pourquoi je me vois pas
aller à tel endroit
c'est épuisant oui je vois tout l'écrire
puis
en voilà dit ça me fait dire que puisque
souvent les gens sont polis mag ont
dressé sur j'aime j'avais vu leur
expliquer parce que justement il va
recevoir ça c'est un breton est occupé
ah ouais tabarnak mais c'est vrai qu'on
est occupé on peut tous se libérer on
peut tout selon il ya toujours une façon
de se libérer quand tu veux vraiment jeu
comme je voyais pourquoi je me vois pas
aller à tel tournage dès la fin ça me
rejoint - puisque la personne me répond
en annonce parce que je pense et est à
la fois remanié comme à quoi on peut
s'appeler on va en jaser pas son mot
sert les réponses de mon gérant sont
importants parce que veut pas il me
représente
on a un charles être occupés on on va me
dire la vérité on choisit pour quoi que
ça me tente pas y aller oui mais city la
table c'est vraiment un honneur puis on
leur souhaite toutes sortes d'herbes
offre plus de week-end dans le camp des
vêtements métier on rit on a parlé
tantôt il ya des noms sa réussite et
puis je vous sais pas trop pourquoi
écouter le dise pourquoi des fois ça
peut être des raisons nous faut et c'est
vrai qu'on va le temps des fouets sont
des artistes mais tant qu'ils sont en
studio sont pas des créations des fois
ci comme qui me bloque tout le reste ou
de semer mais ses droits parce qu'il ya
un spectacle avec 1
le c'est un projet qui est pas au monde
encore là mais qu'un humoriste qui est
bien établie puis on se connaît bien
vite et comme à mener cette réforme
phare de quoi enchanter la enfin ça
arrive je reçois le descriptif de
l'émission ça concorde poc et je
commence ça j'aime savoir sur mais
j'aime pas ce faire tu l as far as tu
peux pas je pourrai pas enfin que pia et
m'a demandé à y est j'ai pas eu de suite
je ne t'ai pas encore répondu oh ben non
puis je mangeais rate ça c'est répondre
qu'elle soit aujourd'hui gilles d'âge
mental dit la vie voix j'y réponds je ne
serai pas avec toi même si je t'aime
d'amour pour tel et tel talent tels deux
raisons sa concordent pas c'est comme
avec en lice merci de me le dire
ce réseau ça s'apprend une connaissance
de soi de ça prend une aptitude à être
capable d'exprimer un réel manque qu est
ce qu est ce que toi tu souhaites je
sais pas tout le monde qui est sûr parce
que ça prend quand même des balises pour
refuser certaines affaires selon des
valeurs
oh oui mais ça n'a pas pris oui puis en
même temps pas non mais dans ce sens que
ce sens et je trouve 5 parce que je
connais mais ce sera parfait pour moi je
me respecte si je fais ça ne respecte
pas je vous écris je vais te faire chier
après - le tournage durera pas bien la
personne mais en breton étaient tous là
aujourd'hui te le dis j'aime passer aux
fesses
le sacristain ceux ci vont nuire à tout
le monde pour nuire à tout le tournage
tu va nuire à tout le temps qu'elle soit
à la base je m'interdisais à la limite
ça te fera chier 25 minutes un militaire
un petit journée mais je sais que tout
le temps tu vas me dire ah ben c'est
quoi
tabet puis je le disais même j'ai
fleuret sujet dans le podcast avec jay
jay plus + tétouan main dans ma vie mais
c'est comme plus tu patines plus été bon
mais plus tu es toi même que tu te
respecte plus c'est facile plus habituel
après en être connaître je le sais ça
c'est énorme ça c'est wing fait que même
si je t'aime d'un mot je dirais pas
faire ça parce que c'est pas moins mais
c'est tout et par exemple mais moi je
peux pas marquer avec toi bataille de
notre émission un jour on se bat ouais
mais ça c'est vraiment pas tout le monde
puis de personnellement moins chic c'est
quelque chose que j'ai appris
dernièrement ou que j'essaie de
travailler plus dernièrement de dire
même si y'a plein benfissa force
non non non c'est sûr c'est pas moi
c'est toujours que ce projet de 7
amènerait parlement de l'argent vraiment
de la visibilité doit être probablement
plus de monde ils connaissent savent
sûrement plein de côté positif mais
crise
si c'est pas toi d'avoir la la la clarté
d'esprit de pouvoir dire non ça vaut pas
le coup
pour moi mon nom c'est ça c'est pas tout
le monde qui va de faire ce nom puis il
faut parce que j'ai l'impression que
d'après ce que j'en règlement des fois
c'est la peur de manquer quelque chose
là pas de moi mais je pourrais peut-être
connaître telle personne
il ya un autre chemin pour il voit un
autre chemin
ça va c'est pas le tien c'est pourquoi
tu accepté à ce que les mares pour six
mois laisse quand même
l'édito la vie est courte mais si moi
faire de quoi que tempo des ultimes mans
est ce qu'on souhaite à tout le monde
envie de ce qu'on souhaite à nous mêmes
c'est d'être heureux c'est le temps qui
passe à faire quelque chose dans lequel
tu t'es pas bien du temps qui passe
tandis que tu es bien pour nous c'est un
temps limité dans une journée dans une
vie on a eu un temps limité à petite
échelle car je commence à sortir avec ma
blonde
des fois après le super g pour ça que
c'est une couru avec moins jusqu'à
maintenant la crise a aimé postale est
inepte et vice versa gonflé mais pas
ceux qui ont un cours plus courte je
courais avec moi ça va être le fun parce
que je vous dois faire après ce prix non
mais je mojaïsk une des choses aillent
plus dans la vie courez courez courez
qu'un bon temps je peux voir qui prend
la troisème et courez pas de bâtons je
vois pas jaïs au courant
mais choisit à l'annoncé au début à bout
d un peu grandi jusqu'à maintenant mais
c'est des fois faut mettre de l'eau dans
son vin
on va les marchés ça me tente pas plus
de sortir à soir mais je suis prêt à les
marchés ce jeu on peut aller marcher ça
me fait plaisir mais pas cours et parce
que je vois des agréables ou
désagréables même pas choix là on fait
deux coins de rue watt en tabarnak
après moins d'avoir finalement fait de
quoi ça me tentait pas soit en crise que
j'arrête de courir souhaite soldes
c'était tout à bien en sport ça va être
catastrophique avec voici tout ce soir
revient me retrouver après ou vas-y pas
mais maintenant c'est correct mais d'un
début était quand même en voyant crise
pourquoi ces totems ça très heureuse moi
ça me rend pas heureux
féler je ne ferai pas un combat de rue
et vice versa des fois je fais des trucs
non je vois pas
j'en reviens dans 12 heures la très vive
et des cv vous sinon c'est d'un point de
vue relationnel c'est important au début
de la relation de se respecter le début
parce que c'est emballant un batteur une
piqûre naturaliste fait un max allez
courir le ch'ti ça fait deux ans que les
femmes ça me tente plus je décide que le
leur dit non je sais qu'elle est à
mornac ça fait deux ans qu'on court
ensemble plus dur plus là ça peut être
problématique parce que tu es entrant
une lame est quoi ce que toc toc a été
ta beauté 100% toi michael otto vendu
quelque chose qui était pas toi elle
était panique c'est bien mais beaucoup
pour moi j'ai une demi très très bonne
amie c'est drôle qu'on en parle la paix
une semaine et plaxo chaque fois qu'on
voyait des soupes installe femme à barbe
plasma tout à me raconter pour la ch'ti
pour lui oui on met de l'eau dans notre
vin en coupe c'est normal mais quand
elle sait comment vivait pour lui mme
houde saint écrit ja ja revenait pour la
rend pas compte dans dernières années je
commence à m'en doutais de douter de
quoi elle était bien que peut-être que
je pensais pas un mois mais oui mais
putilo un chapeau de sacrément de bons
salaires faisant selon un axe et sert
aussi à tous ces deux pour plaire c'est
parce que en même temps elle est ici
l'important de poids jugé le team où je
connais son histoire et qu'elle l'a pas
eu facile avec d'autres gorgue là en
avions quand même qu'ils étaient bons
fait que l'acide alpha jet garde pour le
garder à se plier à ces exigences
ça reste quand même un bon garçon
l'autre cela dit c'est lui savait pas
lui non
mais c'est bon pour tout le monde
les amis le couple le travail n'importe
quoi c'est pour ça que peu importe
l'ampleur du projet mind se donne quatre
cent mille pour animer quelque chose
c'est comme un non moi je me ferais pas
ça je m'attends ce salut bonjour vous
salut bonjour le premier sur n'importe
qui on me dit salut bonjour
c'est un million par année du direct
cinq jours tous les trois ans est arrivé
non mac os 10 - un million - dans mon
compte je vois tu heureux parce qu'en
plus je fais des choses soient jamais
jamais de la vie
le même pas un bon jeu rien savoir non
puis mettant ça me retombe une animation
du tout cette housse et kate n'ont pas
encore leur rien à voir avec l'émission
c'est juste que je compte pas dans le
glas de la chaussée pour moi est ce que
je serais capable de faire
probablement comme un du monde tu veux
dire c'est que comme je le fais très
bien à sa couleur à sa sauce et
merveilleux le vent de jeunesse de cette
émission la cpi est impeccable bien mais
moi ça serait plus sa limite d'autres se
veut me garder dans les mêmes cordes
ça serait plus l'amour est dans le pré
ça serait plus chez nous la campagne
double même si maria janvier est
exceptionnelle le tube est assez belle
l'accord liste et g10 correct sauf que
maintenant je vois vraiment pour des
enfants
yat il fallut camani tu t'assois piste
et qui c'est qui ça me retombe
qu'est ce qu'ils aiment ou site
interactif nature et il s'est
constamment chaque soin moi j'ai dit
sauve le plusieurs années à guillaume
pineau que vous connaissez
jeudi guillaume parce qu'elle m'a donné
il ya eu différentes parle dans sa ville
jésus - des fois je réfute juste un
petit ruisseau
moi je peux pas me coucher le soir c'est
ça mon travail ma blonde va se coucher
moi je peux pas je vais aller de bordés
mon amour de chanter une chanson va te
donner un bec ça me fait plaisir
sauvage peut pas marcher dessus fogel
mon petit moment moi même peu importe la
journée que j'ai eus je suis seul dans
le salon les lumières tamisées des fois
je dans le noir complet
je regarde par la fenêtre je pense à ma
journée cependant c'est comment je me
sens je tue bien parce que je t'ai eu
des fois je suis reconnaissant envers
deux ans que je t'ai bonne place je
pense à ma journée de demain ne peut
plus faire comme le vide ça ça me
ressemble bambins target et puis après
ça je me couche puis deux puis à scott
plusieurs années même je peux aussi le
faire encore j'ai jamais demandé mais
pinot meunier me dit qu'il faisait sur
chaque soir avant de se coucher mais ça
va vraiment aider chacun sa technique il
y en a qui m'écoutent cravate à berne
que si fous rires ce stylo pas de
problème c'est pas grave mais moi c'est
important je repense à tout ma blonde
que ce que j'aime de maman pourquoi je
l'étais leurs frais ça ne sourit cette
petite mise à jour de toutes les deux
aussi dans ma taille
ça va je te coucher la taille du temps
c'est un bon exercice d'intériorisation
puis de se recentrer justement ce qu'est
ce qui était à notre avis qu'est ce qui
était un peu vite tellement importante
et on le sait le on est dans un monde
lorsque tu devais depuis que s'arrêter
de même puis réfléchit serra pas tout le
monde prend du temps parce maintenant
porte dans mon show jean arthuis je vous
dit entre autres au sujet dans mon show
il y en a un des fleurs sauf une
puis à travaillerai jacent les jeunes
écoutent des fausses ferme si je sens
que j'ai déposé une petite graine dans
la tête des jeunes pilotes
je sais qu'elle va sauver l'accord je
suis personnellement quel peut-être même
pas elle-même direct dans le char
sortait du stationnement
je sais qu'ils vont se dire tout aurait
répondu quoi c'était quand il parlait de
ça me tente à la fois
et le souci de donner un exemple parle
des enfants
ouais je parlais bien je dis c'est
important de savoir pourquoi on veut des
enfants
c'est juste que je dis pas ce que je
viens d'être autour de moi que ces dites
leur demande pas de jugement est
pourquoi tous les enfants c'est souvent
pour ma blanc on estime qu'ils aient
joué dans je sais me mais on s'est
mariés ils ont une maison bien
fallait rappeler les jambes il n'y a pas
de bonne ou mauvaise réponse des fois
j'ai l'impression puis des fois c'est
parce que j'ai dit mais une question par
exemple si j'ai pas de bonnes premières
réponses mais viennent question en plus
moi j'ai trop souvent entendu des amis
dira mais on en voulait à mon instit
judo de colis ça à l'eau le père absent
elle laisse pas l'argent ces études
place en psychologie de suite le tc a
voulu céder fouesnant région par région
c'est souvent une colle moi mes amis en
général c'est pas trop où ils en sont
déjà coordonné avec la fille qu'on que
nous secondaire puis ça fait longtemps
qu'ils sont ensemble
c'est bien on s'est même job dans la
construction dans quelque chose dans la
ferme familiale
c'est super sont heureux mais je les
aime d'amour mais des fois par rapport à
ça j'ai l'impression qu'ils oublient
qu'on évolue que les êtres humains ont
changé moi j'ai pas le même samedi au
voleur une heure j'ai évolué les deux
affaires et puis des fois les chemins ne
sais pas pourquoi des foyers des coupes
après 7,8 en 12 ans séparent on t'a
rendu ailleurs c'est cette fois compter
avec la fille de plus de 14 ans crise
qui a rendu à 23 ans elle a vu des
enfants
ça se peut tout en veux pas ça se peut
de sus c'est pour ça que je dis jeudi au
public je fais juste des justes le droit
moi de ne pas avoir d'enfants c'est
juste que je dis le public sur wii s'est
arrêté là voit pas souvent les gens
jugent aussi quand tu dis bâtons en bois
dont j'aurais pas d'en faire un style
les jeunes ils savent pas comment deal
avec ça c'est pas le chemin habituel en
général étant en couple marié ou non le
du monde a des enfants leur sont
déboussolés j'ai quand même parfois
suscité par ses bons copains
ce programme c'est de ça que je parle
dans le show puis je sais que ça les
fait réfléchir et oui ça c'est
tristement en gros ce que je veux dire
là mais trop souvent on va me dire
encore j'étais à la place des arts le
groupe de jona une couple de semaines
sous dépendance et qui s'est diffusé il
ya deux mois vient me voir a dit moi je
suis mère de trois enfants
si c'était à refaire jamais j'aurais nav
un hit à ban ki pendant un temps la taca
tac tac tac tant par les débitants tôt
alors que du pétrole est sis à anne
seguin ghana claude ariel
c'est comme ça je n'en avais pas pensé à
moi j'en ai fait part comme tu dit elle
j'en ai fait parce que on en dise
pression sociale mes parents quand vous
autres vous allez ailleurs nous amener
des petits jamais je me suis dit avec
peut-être que je peux pas avoir d'enfant
moi aussi j'ai en effet geyser mspa je
les aime pas mais quand est-ce que moins
jamais j'aurais eu d'enfant c'est en
fait à côté qui triplent une corde
autour du cou des enfants qui sont
partis sans aller dans le camping
sauvage
ça me fait vraiment rire ce que tu dis
là parce que avant il ya un chalet avec
un ami que le maintenant il y avait en
norvège
prieto québec pour un bon petit bout de
temps pire est que ses deux enfants pitt
s'est dit au québec on se voyait tous
les jours avec maintenant il est en
norvège fait quand je vois plus petit au
québec
je dis amen comme tu est ici le thêta
montréal on petit frère de quoi et
dimanche oui sauf que si dans cette
plage horaire depuis les enfants vont
être le dérange tu fais nom même du vote
voir tous ces faits que l'on est allé
nos meetings c'est au fon trop polis à
naval hockey parce qu'il ya des enfants
partout qui jouent dans des bois et j'ai
eu pitié on jouait plus je fais je gomme
maintiennent
je pense que tous les enfants je peux
sourire plus regardé autour de lui
ironiquement il dit quoi mène tu trouves
pas son coup le saas en réseau nas de
déduire les personnes qui dit que ses
potes il ya personne qui dit ne s'attend
pas à faire des choses exactes mais dis
moi tu penses tu que de revenir au
québec puis de voir mes amis cela seul
pour les promeneurs j'aimerais ce fils
et moi j'aimerais ça si la personne qui
dit que ce c'est pas nécessairement
colle tout le temps ce que tendance et
c'est tellement beau plateau des enfants
cm2 6e mes enfants qu'ils adorent le
plus que tout au monde et crise personne
qui dit que c'est pas nécessairement
100% positif c'est exact fait qu au
moins tu peux y pensé réfléchi que
maurel mais c'est surtout d'être prête
pour ce jeudi cité fondation mentale
sont solides
moi je veux des enfants pour ma
progéniture pour les voir grandir pour
leur apprendre des choses puis oui je
sais que des fois c'est de la merde mais
je suis prêt à soppe ça me tente de le
faire avec une femme que j'aime de bâtir
ça je veux aller jusqu'au bout
faisant 38 des enfants moi et d'être
ferme à coucher il faut que je me donne
encore lisse mais ce et des fois que je
vois pas ce que maintenant tous mes amis
ont des enfants depuis des fois des à
l'isaf depuis son record c'est normal et
fois d'avoir des mauvais jours n'est pas
par an mais juste assez conscient pour
voir que c'est pas facile d'être parents
mais le cd fois moi j'ai juste un chiot
à maison le tir dès fois le ticket cash
garde comme semble urgent taux de monju
tabarnak toute mon attention c'est un
chiot
mais des fois il ya un axe est
constamment sur chaque jour sur cinq les
enfants ces lots sur le sens que
fondamentalement il en voulait pas seul
ça c'est local alors un ballet les
enfants mais si peu importe c'est quoi
quel moment de l'année c'est toujours ça
c'est pour lui une mauvaise jour même
ses gammes
c'est anna voulait en effet ces lots
pour tout le monde
l'eau polluée mais ces lots pour les
kids c'est parce que ça c'est parti et
lui peut pas aller voir si beau il faut
aussi garder deux enfants parce que pour
une fois sablons à bois sorte ça me fait
ça me fait capoter
c'est pour ça que j'en parle dans
chouchou c'est important de jeu ce soir
un porte parole bien au contraire
dans le choc de la 10e puis pour les
enfants c'est de la main les enfants
c'est merveilleux la famille
probablement le plus beau concept qui a
passé pour ça je dis je fais juste des
gétules droit mou de pas avoir d'enfant
c'est juste que je dis c'est puis en
écho à ce poste m paysans enfin ses
légendes
ils cherchent ils cherchent des bébés
ils cherchent toujours à savoir pourquoi
je veux pas d'enfant c'est juste une
décision comme ça parce que j'aime ma
vie comme ça passe je sens pas le besoin
d'en avoir
ça me tente pas de consacrer ma vie à
cet enfant là parce qu'on va se dire où
on a enfin cessé
j'ai consacré au moins dix-huit premiers
à lui même le street art dit tout avis
le maire a dit c'est plutôt c'était
plutôt que vous aviez tout en haut de 18
ans parce que je crois que tu fais mais
ce que vous tapez pas tout le temps vous
n'êtes pas tout le temps voici moi ça on
est 9 milliards
courbier qu'on est rendus là ces mecs
comme moi ça me tente pas aux jeunes je
ne sais pas représentants probablement
d'un futur papa et meurent encore du
temps pour y penser mais je dirais que
ça c'est clair
j'aime tant tout est anonyme des puits
jeu à vingt content qu'on se laisse je
laisse ma peau me manque c'est un gros
problème mais bon je veux lancer je veux
juste être bâtisse de l'autre truc que
tu me dises que c'est en pensant à ce
qui était dit quelque chose c'est à dire
en tout qui me ramenait une conversation
que j'avais plutôt requis hier s'est
entendue dire tu es ma blonde fait
partie prenante de ma vie puis on s'est
fait dire dans un commentaire au ps
commencent toutes ses phrases en disant
lo'jo par là que ma blonde
parce que je pense des idées beaucoup
c'est vrai puis un petit quelque chose
en tout qui me rappelait une convention
avec ma blonde hier qui était de 2 0l
mamelon à redire c'est une chance qu'on
a fait
occupation deux parce que l'on est en
train de travailler sur une énorme
projet qu'on peut pas encore dévoiler
mais qui sait comme une chance qu'on a
fait et occupation double on s'est
rencontrés nous a mené le bal me suis
dit je crois c'est encore en moi je
crois en toi pour savoir que si on
n'avait pas fait occupation de on aurait
fait autre chose ou est ce qu'on se
serait dit à une petite chance que j'aie
prophète occupation deux parce que tu
sais ce que je fais maintenant
tantôt tu disais que c'était pas
nécessairement le jeu n'en est plus là
je m'en vais plus c'était quoi qu'on
parlait mais de dire qu'une île de dire
que rien qui arrive pour rien je pense
que c'est la bonne vision de la du truc
je pense que c'est on fait avec ce qui
arrive vite et je vais un peu plus que
qu'on parlait mais cette réflexion
l'homme est apparu en disant il n'y a
pas de pas de chemin en parler des
mariages pour la fille c'est ça
exactement il ya rien qui arrive pour
rien mais je me dis il n'y a pas de
chemin il nous est prédestiné mais on
fait avec le chemin qu'on grâce au
moment où est-ce que ça arrive
puis c'est juste la réflexion qui avec
sa parlure le jeu je n'aime pas tant que
la garde
y'a rien car pour moi c'est ce grand
macabre ballet salut
les schistes veau de chalais pas tant
externes est pas ça dépend comment
connaître après tout si parce qu'il ya
rien qui arrive pour rien et quelque
chose du destin là dedans qui qui comme
je pense que tu fais avec ce qui arrive
c'est comme ça sous-entend que c'est ce
qu'on n'est pas parfait contrôle de nos
vies puis moi je pense qu'on n'y quand
même à dire en contrôle pas parfait mais
ton métier certaines limitations qui
sont très déterminés mais après c'est un
maudit contrôle sur ta ville c'est ok
c'est tout si toile capitaine du bateau
sous ce look discutable qui l'appuient
porte bonheur ou du maroc vont arriver
ça va tout responsable des foyers
d'affaires externe hors du contrôle et
apprécier rigueur est pour rien deux
tournées du négatif au positif ça c'est
là comme la bonne façon de l'interpréter
je pense le ticket qui m'est arrivé
c'est la marque qui se fixe au guichet
l'ex comment quelque peu morbide dessus
comment je peux tourner sans positif
mais mettez moi c'est l'idée plus
ésotérique du concept sur mon jeu
j'accroche plus bas jégou tu te dis je
suis pas d'accord avec tout ce qu'elle
vient de dire mais ce n'est pas vrai
parce que je t'aime accord avec tout ce
que tu viens de dire
l'eau je pense que je pense qu'on dit
tout la même affaire en même temps moi
je pense que rien qui arrive pour rien
et quand il arrive quelque chose à ce
moment à la loge plantes à feuillage
lors on compose avec avec series avec ce
qui arrive je comprends ce que tu
désires l'ésotérique seul mais je pense
je pense pas le bon python a pesé moi je
pensais plus cela dit on contrôler mon
plus grand ça la rend 1,6 contre ce que
je peux contrôler c'est son hygiène de
vie je m'entraîne dessus parce que je
mange ce que je travaille fort ce que je
vois des mecs de la mer même plus plus
plus profondément ce que tu disais de
dire est ce que je me respecte moi même
aussi voir ce serait dans l'acquisition
watch prendre aux assauts ça affecte ce
qu'on trouve ce que je puis quand je dis
rien n'arrive pour rien tu passais
souvent je trouve un christ de hasard
qui est
odin participation à od autant je m'en
allais faire une grosse affaire avec mon
père puis il ya eu l'accident de charlie
est mort sur le coup et du congrès là
y'a rien n'arrive pour rien c'est du col
est ce à dire mais je dois composer avec
ce qui arrive c'est plus haut des
poteaux ce que saturne et tendons
scolaire là c'est plus ça mais parce que
moi je pense plus à contrôler ce qu'on
peut contrôler mais le reste fodil avec
ça donc je pense que nos deux phrases
finalement se combinent bien d'ailleurs
rien n'arrive pour rien par rapport à ce
que tu contrôle pas puis quand la vie
d'envoi un défi l'autre cause de deux
choix rendu le quintal des films ouais
bah oui bah oui tout genre qu'il montre
sur les manchots genre faute une
difficulté à lhassa sait ce qu'est le
web sont pas un autre branche saint cyr
hôtel mais d'où l'importance de deux de
ses respectés le connaître sa valeur
parce que ça aille dans simona carey a
changé plus chère d'un corps paul a
chargé plus comme avant d'aller là
dessus qu'il connaît et également de
d'affronter certaines situations parce
qu'on était forces et faiblesses ça
c'est moins la corne sage
des fois non voici juge pas capable
d'affronter ça je me sens affaire ben je
pleure tu vas chercher de l'aide de ses
programmes connaissent en a plus des
petits plus apte à demander de l'aide
parce que tu cites est au bout de deux
tailles ressources comme chris faujas ai
dit je veux pas tout prendre exactement
quand on connaît moins chose quand el
kabbach vesti nom des fois faut tu te
sois toi même tu fasses soit une
j'ai aussi je me connais je verrai pas
le but de tout ça si j'ai pas là et de
telle ou telle personne sur celle été
chanceux l'institut maurice dans la vie
ça va barder chance il fait de la
musique dans la vie tu es chanceux oui
et non si richard sujet départ
extraordinaire
j'ai eu toutes les ressources les outils
pour ça fonctionne mais non parce que
j'ai travaillé j'ai pris mon destin en
main puis il ya personne qui qui qui qui
me l'a donné toute une année encore lors
des prochains jeux dans le sens de
travailler quand même qui reste de
bûcheron pour arriver
mais tes pattes est chanceux d'avoir été
choisi pour telle émission kitamissa
amap parce que des gens qui travaillent
fort comme tout il y en a peut-être 10
puis crise c'est toi qu'on ait choisi
est ce que c'est toi qu'on ne choisit
pas ce que c'est ouattara est le plus
fort on ne saura jamais il ya quand même
une partie d'impondérables là-dedans
d'où le fait que souvent d'humour en
musique les lits les chanteurs des fois
on avait tout cas pour moi une piste
aussi bonne aussi bon ok mais regarde
l'autre sur ton dans rien n'arrive pour
rien d'autre chose pour toi puis plus
souvent qu'autrement c'est pour ça que
je me soumets à dire cette phrase
l'envié sens parce que qualys plus
souvent qu'autrement c'est autant des
fois je commence peut-être à christophe
aux 8 à la sphère doit pas gagner tel
truc mais finalement six mois plus tard
tu comprends pourquoi une changeait pas
eu ce contrôle créé ça m'a empêché de
faire lui qui me tente est vraiment dans
le fond c'est fait une partie de chance
oui non les impondérables le leitmotiv
de tous le lendemain de la guerre c'est
ton propre moteur donc ce que tu
contrôles ce qui permet d'avancer à
plein régime
merci ça achève leur mettant des
défections bientôt deux afin qu est-ce
que nicole était toujours là ok c'est
bon c'est bon quand on l'espère du
podcast où il a créé non tout est mia et
s est mis le paquet cette semaine j'ai
adoré le podcast plein d'expressions qui
se sont dit qu'ils sont vraiment appris
à parier que répondriez ça c'est de là
bas les autres c'est une question pour
ça ouais non quoi chacun là où est-ce
qu'on écoute parce qu'on m'écoute studio
fr non parce que moi j'attends c'est que
c'est le studio fait un film est fait
est fait
non mais attendez se poursuit à travers
le québec on va tomber comme c'est
important pour un camp ma tournée aux
pics d'appels fois partie des
expressions québécoises que j'aime bien
même si toutes les autres au fur et à
mesure meiway au pp rappelle sinon les
greniers que salut bonjour les jeudis ce
n'est pas aux ombres d'où je recommence
à l'automne chaque jeudi matin
voilà sinon ici l os en boîte on paye ma
page page instagram soit plus est au
courant de tout ce qui se passe en temps
et lieu merci infiniment
c'était un grand symbole d'abord les
concours merci à ceux qui ont écouté le
bas